Housewives and Means Committee I find
that due to the state of emergency
declared by the governor as a result of
covid-19 dynamic and in accordance with
house rule 67 the governor's emergency
auditor number 12. pursuant to executive
order
2020-04 this public bond is authorized
to meet electronically
this is a public hearing on sex bills
today and as
there is time we will accept those that
we've already have heard previously
please note there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen contemporarily to
this meeting however in accordance with
the emergency order I am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporarily during this
meeting through the zoom electronic
platform and the public has access to
contemporarily listen and if necessary
participate to this meeting by Zoom by
the zoom platform or by telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available in the house
calendar into the electronic calendar on
the general court website
the notice for this mating complies with
house rules and RSA 91a anyone who has a
problem accessing a meeting should call
271-3600 or email HCS
leg.state.nh.us in the event the public
is unable to access to access the
meeting the meeting will be adjourned
and rescheduled I want to introduce the
staff that are on the meeting assisting
us Christopher Shea and Jennifer Ford
please note that all votes that have
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll call vote
start the meeting by taking a look when
each member states that present please
also State whether there is anyone in
the room with you during this meeting
which is required under the right to
know law
representative University in the roles
thank you Mr chair today is February 17
2021 and we're going to do a roll call
vote uh
we'll begin with represented I'm sorry
we'll do a roll call not a vote uh we'll
begin with representative abrami here in
my home and stratum uh
subbing for representative Mary Griffin
is representative Joe Alexander uh good
morning uh representative Alexander I'm
here in Goffstown my roommates are in
and out of the room thanks for having me
uh subbing for representative Jordan
ovary is representative Kim Lang
Dr Ryan I'm in my home here in San
Martin New Hampshire my son and a
contractor may be running around behind
me very good welcome to representative
Ober
here in Hudson at home with the usual
six cats representative Doucet
uh good morning here in Salem my home
office alone
uh representative berstein is your
humble clerk today he's at his home
office in Nottingham representative
Robert Elliott
yeah and my wife is uh in the
living room somewhere representative
jinigian
here in my home office in Salem and my
wife and daughter are somewhere in the
house representative Nunes
thank you representative bursting good
morning I am in my home in Pelham
representative Baxter
uh he texted me saying he was running
late we'll get back to him uh
representative spilsbury here at my home
in Charlestown alone representative
Tudor here in Northwood alone
representative Army
here in my home in Lebanon alone
representative Richard Ames yes I'm here
and Jeffrey in my home office alone
representative Southworth here in Dover
alone representative Malloy
here in Greenland alone representative
Thomas Schomburg uh I'm at the Payson
library in Concord Hospital alone
representative Edith Tucker
I'm in Randolph alone representative go
Marlow I am in Swansea alone
representative laughman Thomas lofman
representative laughman representative
gorg good morning I am present and alone
representative hacken Phillips good
morning I I'm joining you from my office
in Concord alone representative James
Murphy good morning I am in my home
office in Hanover representative major
good morning I'm in my office in my home
and my wife is in the house
okay I'm going to Mark representative
Baxter absence so Mr chair there are 22
present and two
uh not here
thank you representative
we will start the public hearing
on House Bill 102 enact relative to
worldwide combined reporting for unitary
businesses under the business practice
tax
and representative Sean Schomberg says
Define sponsor and representative
Schaumburg the choice
thank you Mr chairman this is
representative Schamberg Merrimack 4
towns of Wilmot and Sutton uh
for our new members
of the of the ways and means I did send
a two attachments to representative
major and representative brahmi I will
resend those to everyone
when I get back home today uh one is an
article that was printed in tax notes
and the other are the bullet points that
I was using for House Bill 102 so that
uh if everybody remembers last year I
gave a 45-minute presentation I'm trying
to keep it just down to five or six
minutes this year
um
this uh House Bill 102 is being
reintroduced from the former House Bill
1567 which last year went to interim
study uh a good criteria
as I mentioned of a good tax policy as
we all and we know in ways it means is
the equable treatment
of all taxpayers and this one is dealing
with the BPT tax
just as a quick review
New Hampshire relies on its business
profits tax more than any other state
and most countries and I started
researching how our state
taxes profits of multinational
corporations
operate in our state and elsewhere after
reading on January 2019 article titled a
simple fix for a 17 billion dollar
loophole
and how states can reclaim Revenue loss
to Offshore tax Havens and that was by
the uh itep Institute on Taxation and
economic policy and the American
sustainable sustainable Business Council
uh the design of this bill
is to counteract income tax avoidance by
multinational corporations
via a profit shifting to tax Havens and
foreign jurisdictions
my concern is that
New Hampshire does not treat all
multinational taxpayers equitably with
domestic taxpayers and that the unitary
Waters Edge method grants an
unconstitutional advantage
to foreign-based multinationals
operating our state
understand that I'm not opposed to
foreign Acquisitions of New Hampshire
companies what I'm opposed to is foreign
corporations operating in New Hampshire
that pays zero or minimal minimal
corporate income taxes
this house bill 102 would reform our New
Hampshire BPT tax
accounting method from Water's Edge to
worldwide combined reporting method that
when mandate companies include their U.S
profits held in offshore tax Haven
accounts when calculating their taxes
this profit shifting is accomplished
through
basically inter-company transactions via
transfer pricing at supposedly an arm's
length when dealing with a subsidiary it
would be like company a
owns subsidiary Company B and instead of
doing what they would do with most
companies that are out in the public
uh
they supposedly are saying we are
dealing with an arm's length when we ask
for a price for we want to buy this from
them just like we would do with somebody
uh another company out in the public
the
transactions basically are treated as if
unrelated and not affiliated and in my
research with the GAO the IRS and even
here in New Hampshire uh
the Supreme New Hampshire Supreme Court
had mentioned in a case in 1999
we point out that the water's edge
method was adopted for the benefit of
foreign businesses and this has brought
me now to why I reintroduced this bill
um
what this does is it causes domestic
companies that do not have multinational
Affiliates to pay a higher effective tax
rate than their multinational
competitors or domestic
competitors I would like to
uh
to suggest Mr chairman
that this Ways and Means Committee
hopefully vote to retain this bill
so that it weighs a means study
committee can delve into all the aspects
of the worldwide combined reporting
versus unitary Waters Edge accounting
method and that all members would be
able to attend
thank you for your time and
consideration
thank you for your testimony with
representative Schoenberg questions of
Representative Schoenberg
let me get my
I'm going here
representative Bronson
thank you Mr chair I don't I don't
really have specific questions I'm quite
familiar with this from last term
um and I think we've decided last term
that we we definitely needed to study
this thoroughly before we acted on any
any bill that would change the way we
treated the water's edge companies
so
um I I would support I would support uh
us taking a look at it more if anything
just an educational thing
um I think the dra is willing to also uh
support uh being involved
um because it's been such a long time
since we've that even the dra has looked
at this issue I mean going back a couple
of decades I think
uh I view this more as educational for
everybody and I I would support a motion
to uh retain and study thank you
okay
representative Ames
[Music]
yeah thank you and
thank you representative schanberg for
your extraordinary work on this
really really important subject and
really really complicated and hard to
understand subject
so much appreciated
um and I share representative abrami's
view that this merits close attention by
the committee and it can't be done in
the rush of uh getting bills
uh through to be considered by the full
house right now but it could be
well considered uh if retained
um and my question to you representative
Schamberg is a request that you spell
out a little bit more
how this transfer pricing works
um how is it that
a multinational transnational
Corporation
um
can through
um through being viewed as a Water's
Edge company
manipulate prices in effect
so that what we see here in New
Hampshire or what the United States is
more broadly as the attributable
property to
this country or this state
is much less than what it really should
be
the answer though can you speak to that
I can speak to it in a general
proposition uh
the
foreign parent groups with U.S
subsidiaries
uh like all multinational corporations
uh
as stated by the GAO and the IRS
May engage in income shifting to
low-tech jurisdictions in order to evade
not only New Hampshire Texas but to
evade U.S taxes
um
multi
National corporate group whether it's
U.S owned or foreign owned may have
subsidiaries in countries outside the
United States
or corporate tax rates may be lower and
uh
corporate structure
can provide a scope for
income shifting through practices such
as manipulation of the transfer price
from
a subsidiary of theirs
that as I was saying earlier that maybe
sells it to a non-affiliated company at
ten dollars
would sell or transfer the price to
maybe
fifteen dollars between each other and
this is that arm's length approach that
the uh
that is concerning
is that we're not seeing the actual real
profits that could be taxed
in New Hampshire
um
I I guess that's the best I can do with
that right now representative Ames if I
could do a follow-up
follow up
um
so I I've seen examples of how this
plays out where a subsidiary in a low
tax jurisdiction outside of the United
States
um
is uh reporting
taxable profits to that jurisdiction
that are greater than the gross national
product of that jurisdiction
um
reflecting the phenomenon that you're
trying to describe have you seen
examples like that
oh
I don't have any particular
uh information other than articles that
have been
publishing tax notes one of the most
recent ones
is what um
Coca-Cola
has recently been charged
with uh profit shifting uh
that they had originally had approval
from the IRS but it's like you said they
went to a uh it was a royalty charge
and they were
almost three billion dollars that the
IRS is finally
been able to hopefully recoup for the
United States
I'd have to go into my research and my
papers to find you some examples
fine thank you
okay
um I do have something to say on this is
that
I did talk
with the era on this
and they said it is a extremely
complicated issue
and it would take the dra a lot of time
to get up to speed on this because the
last time
it was present in New Hampshire was in
the 80s
and hasn't been used since then
and so that I would recommend
to retain it
and see if we can work for the dra so
that we can all understand what this
really is
so
Mr chairman I'm sorry representation
just a little follow-up
the state of Virginia
is revisiting combined reporting that
they've turned over to a study committee
also
we do have someone within the
continental United States now that is
undertaking a look at this also
all right thank you
uh representative Tucker
uh yes I I must say that last year when
the topic came up I was afraid that I
would
not be able to uh
follow the discussion
and but I think that the really the two
overriding points are that there's a
possibility that there are New Hampshire
companies that are being treated
inequitably to in
in regard to multinationals
and two that we could be missing out on
some tax income
that we should be getting
and it turned out that
there is enough available material
written for people who are not
uh phds and economics so that the
arguments can be followed and I hope
that we can support this retention idea
and have a good study I think we'll
learn a lot about the big picture of
business in New Hampshire at the same
time
representative
thank you Mr chairman
um
last year when we put this into interim
study it was for the same purposes
retained so that we could understand it
better and at that time
we thought that we would be able to do
it last summer last fall and instead we
had coveted on and
in the fall when they finally got to the
point where we could meet as a committee
they had to have every single committee
meet as uh
in order to take care of their interim
study bills they told us we could only
have an hour and a half for both our
interim study bills the other one took
an hour during that hour and a half if I
remember correctly uh and
so we
abandoned abandoned very reluctantly our
ability to do this as a full committee
there were some of us that did meet
on on the Democratic side and we uh have
assembled a lot of of resources human
and and
research-wise that I had hoped we would
be able to share by now but on
this session like the last one is being
so chaotic in many ways that on it's
very difficult under covet for the
legislature that on
it isn't quite finished yet but we will
have a kind of Guide to the literature
on from the people that are most
concerned with this issue and there is
one person in attendees
who I would have hoped my
my testify but you know apparently he
didn't put his hand up uh from that
uh from the sustainable uh business
on I forget exactly what the name of it
is but it's a very large uh Association
of businesses that do not operate
internationally and feel that they are
being competed against
thank you
um anybody else wish to comment attest
or ask questions if not
does the committee feel that we can
accept this bill
we have one person that signed up to
testify and I believe it might be the
one
okay yes representative
a David Morse
a member of the public who signed up to
testify and supported the bill
Mr David Morse
yes hello can you hear me yes
thank you very much
I am uh definitely here on uh on behalf
of myself this time however uh I wanted
to uh comment and support this uh
legislation worldwide combine on
worldwide combined reporting
specifically from a pro-business
standpoint uh just to give you a little
bit about who I am I've been working for
the last eight years
on with the expertise of small business
and other experts regarding the real
world consequences of Water's Edge style
legislation uh my primary focus is
usually on the federal level but we've
been focused also on the state level for
some time uh to be com completely
forthright I was also a minor
contributing author on the paper that
was mentioned by representative
Schamberg as credited by the tax Journal
tax notes
the reason why I support this
legislation is because the water's edge
is a product of a bygone era in
international relations
and in particular this references the
United Kingdom and Japan back in the 80s
when they were pressuring the United
States government
now that entire system has shifted and
both of those countries along with many
others are more concerned about the tax
avoidance of the largest multinational
companies
than they are about protecting
their corporations from U.S taxes
now the effects that were described by
representative Schamberg are very real
there's a tax differential is what it's
known as between Multinational
Enterprises and small domestic companies
now
in the best example that I can give
for anecdote is probably the beer
industry where you have
Anheuser-Busch that has one of the most
complicated subsidiary structures in the
world
and the reason that it developed that
way was so that they could gain a
competitive business advantage using
their subsidiaries uh Anheuser-Busch
inbev you know it's a big long name but
by this point it has management from
Brazil ownership from Europe and
ultimately has managed to avoid paying a
lot of taxes that are local craft
Brewers in the United States and in New
Hampshire end up having to pay
now I will completely admit that New
Hampshire could not solve the entire
full tax disparity by itself uh but it
can remove its contribution to the
problem whenever a state finds itself in
a financial crunch there is inevitably
going to be discussion of raising tax
rates however if you have put the system
in effect where one group is paying a
lower percentage than the other
then when you raise the rates you're
raising and raising them inequitably
so you have to resolve that tax
disparity first between the rates before
you then move on
and raise the rates overall otherwise
you're going to hurt more likely the
small businesses in your own State than
you are
to affect the overall the overall tax
base so that the difficulty is shared
equally amongst all the businesses
now
I am very grateful for this moment to
discuss this with the committee and I
would be happy to answer any questions
you may have for me
questions for Mr Morris
represent Tucker
representative you want to unmute
yourself
could you have our guest please identify
the group that he represents or belongs
to that uh representative Albany
couldn't quite come up with
but Mr Moss oh absolutely absolutely so
I must State for the record that
um my I am here volunteering my my board
did not approve uh my attendance here as
part of the Coalition for a prosperous
America that's the group that I work for
as the tax policy director however this
is a matter under their discussion as to
which whether or not they will be
getting involved more directly on this
issue specifically for New Hampshire
we primarily focus on the federal level
now the group that uh representative Ami
was trying to bring up is a group that I
am affiliated with I've worked with uh
although I'm not paid directly through
uh and I'm not being paid today and that
would be the American sustainable
Business Council
they are a one of the contributing
groups
regarding the
uh regarding the paper that was
mentioned earlier and additionally uh
there is a affiliate uh Coalition called
the salesfactor.org it is a group that
is sponsored by a gentleman by the name
of Mr Bill parks and miss and Mr Parks
is very dedicated to this issue as well
but uh these are all groups that I have
connections to and affiliations with uh
just for the record good that's what I
wanted thank you so much
yes uh thank you Mr
um
thank you for your testimony
um no you know you mentioned
Anheuser-Busch you know years a couple
years ago I dawned on me that the
Anheuser-Busch is no longer an American
company
uh that it's ownership changed hands
um I'm sure there's a lot of that going
on for other businesses as well
um but the real question I have is
although Anheuser-Busch does have a
pretty big footprint here in New
Hampshire are modeling uh in New
Hampshire
but
um
in terms of of other states
representative Schoenberg mentioned
Virginia is starting to look at this do
you know of given given your
affiliations with these different
organizations do you know of other
states that are are even taking a peek
at this at the moment at the moment
there has been some consideration uh
specifically uh last year I believe it
was uh Montana and then there was some
discussion in Oregon as well uh there
the state of Alaska treats their uh
their oil Revenue under a single sales
Factor uh worldwide is my best
understanding of its practical
application already in existence
but
the this has been considered a natural
replacement to what is known as a tax
Haven uh legislation uh in particular
Oregon and Montana had tax Haven
legislation where there was a blacklist
of tax Havens so these are low tax
jurisdictions where the
the uh excuse me
the tax rate of that jurisdiction is so
low that it is creating what is known as
an investment Hub it there that's the
polite way of saying they're taking the
money and they're giving the best tax
rate possible even though they have so
few employees there that it doesn't make
any sense why that money would be stored
there
but it these investment hubs are
particularly
um
energized to go back to those States and
then try to uh lobby as to why they
shouldn't be considered uh part of the
tax Haven list
um that has proven frustrating it was
particularly frustrating in Oregon so
they have uh revised and reviewed how
they're going to do this but they
haven't
um they haven't decided fully how
they're going to tackle the water's edge
legislation yet
um there are other states just to
mention other states on ways that they
plan to deal with this the biggest Focus
has been on what is known as digital
service taxes or uh digital advertising
taxes these uh Maryland just passed one
of these um however
many academics uh include
that I know of believe that it will not
pass constitutional muster unlike the
procedure that would involve getting rid
of the water's edge which has in fact
been proven to uh
the Supreme Court has ruled on it in the
past that the states have the ability to
uh get rid of their Water's Edge if they
so choose so it's got a stronger base to
work from than digital service taxes
which is one of the reasons why I prefer
it
thank you Repton Elliott
you want to unmute representative
thank you Mr chairman uh Mr Lewis I I
want to know because the even the
sponsors uh motion is to retain this
bill uh how long does your organization
need and and others like it to come up
with a bill uh sponsored by anybody here
uh
that would
get rid of this problem of the water's
edge
um
so do you have a time
frame here that you would like to see a
bill ought to pass and how long will
that be thank you
well
this is difficult because it is my
subjective view versus my objective view
but I will say in all honesty
subjectively we Water's Edge would have
been gone yesterday uh however reality
being what it is it makes absolute sense
that uh there would be some sort of
study
um specifically to the state because it
is important to know what kind of
Revenue would be raised from such a
thing but it is important also to note
that without it any uh attempts to
um
move towards say single sales factor
which I also personally support uh will
mean that you usually lose Revenue so
you definitely need to be considering
this issue when you're trying to balance
how much uh Revenue would be lost versus
gained in
um as you the state of New Hampshire
decides what it's going to do about
single sales Factor
um any state that abandons the
three-factor model needs to know that
there is probably going to be a revenue
loss unless there is a uh
abandonment of the water's edge election
and
instead using worldwide combined
reporting so
if we could have it
um sooner the better that but I can't
testify
um in all honesty
that we have a exact timeline written
down we've been
taking a look at what the landscape
looks like in New Hampshire right now
um and as I think uh representative
balmy might have mentioned earlier it
seems very chaotic at times due to cobit
further questions
not thank you Mr Morris there are four
other people that signed up north Norm I
did have a question
if he still lives
is the gentleman still there I'm still
here if you can hear me yeah you
mentioned single sales Factor
um
this chamber the how uh the house is is
against moving quickly to single sales
Factor but the Senate seems to want to
move forward and it's in law right now
did I hear you correctly by saying that
uh Water's Edge companies would benefit
uh if we move forward with single sales
factor is the state
yes it by its very definition uh
especially in smaller States uh it is
more beneficial
to have a Water's Edge with single sales
factor for a company that can
use these techniques and what is known
as being tax aggressive tax planning
aggressive what you're saying is that
your your opinion is that this would be
a negative of revenues to New Hampshire
if this move forward
without being able to look at the data I
can't uh
guarantee it but it that's been my
experience if that's the result uh when
we do the modeling in other states okay
thank you good question uh
representative Bromley
okay
um
there's there's one more attendee David
Juve that would like to speak
okay yes all right we'll bring them in
before I announce the ones in opposition
okay Mr Juve
give him one second to get there
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee I trust you can hear me okay
yes yes thank you for allowing me the
opportunity to testify I did sign up in
opposition to this bill but I didn't do
it soon enough to show up on your list
of uh people wanting to verbally testify
for the record my name is Dave Juve I'm
a senior vice president with the
business and industry Association and we
had reached out to representative
Schomburg late last year I think or
perhaps in January to uh meet with bia's
fiscal policy committee to discuss this
legislation and we were able to have a
good and productive conversation and I
appreciate the representative for making
himself available
however the committee discussion
afterwards seemed to indicate there were
more questions about this uh proposal
than than answers so even though Bia was
opposed to the bill I do encourage uh
the committee to consider are retaining
this although I have to express a
concern with that too and my concern is
this is such a complicated issue and
there are limits to uh committee
activity in terms of a retained bill to
me this would represent as big a change
in tax policy for the state as moving to
market-based sourcing or moving to
single sales Factor both of those issues
had a full-blown commission which gave
the legislature time to really do a deep
dive into the issue it also allowed them
to plan for expert testimony and also to
have expertise on the commission from
people who had experience in those
issues and I recognize that
changing this to a commission
where you can do a deep dive and have a
little more time than having to report
out sometime in the fall has its
limitations to one is uh we're we're not
sure how the Senate would respond to
that and obviously you don't need Senate
support for a retained uh
um a retained Bill all that is to say is
I would support uh the committee doing
uh much more additional work on this
legislation and would certainly support
a commission as opposed to retained
study just to give more chance for
expertise testimony and more time to to
make the right decision thank you Mr
chair I'd be happy to answer any
questions
thank you Mr Jimmy
questions for Mr duvet
saying none there's one more hand raised
in the attendees
uh GBA is all it says
hold on one second oh it's gone oh nope
it's back
we have to be careful because there are
people who know how to work the system
yeah the last minute after listening to
everybody
they jump in
so
and they lowered their hand so okay
we have four people that signed up
to oppose the bill
but they're not going to testify
and they say they're all members of the
public and representing themselves such
as David Matthew did
uh David Morris and these four people
are Alexander Manila
Elliot axelman
Nicholas Thomas and Paul Babb
anybody else listens
justify for or support the bill if not
do you think we have enough information
to uh exec this bill out now
let me know if not then maybe
representative Schoenberg might want to
make a motion we're going we're going to
an executive session and representative
Schoenberg
uh
representative Schamberg would like to
make a motion to
retain this bill House Bill 102 in ways
and means
seconds
representative Sandberg made the motion
to retain the bill second by
representative Bromley any further
discussion on this
motion to retain
I see none uh Mr chairman
I'd just like to ask that we managed to
put considerable time into this if if we
retain it on we do I really would like
to see it retained but to make sure that
that on whoever is really interested in
following this up can can meet several
times in the the late summer or fall
well my feeling is is that
they will be meeting a few times but
they will not it will not be enough and
that they would recommend legislation to
form a commission
so it can be adequately studied with
sufficient time
that would be excellent
uh any further discussion on the motion
to retain
since none of them asked the clerk to
call the roll
thank you Mr chairs I could remind
everyone to unmute and let's let's see
how well we do let's begin the roll call
vote on HB 102 the motion is retained
begin with representative abrami yes
representative Alexander
yes Lang
yes Ober yes it's our first team votes
yes to set
representative Doucet
you're muted Fred
your music yeah and you're not on video
either
Fred you gotta
there we go well and one of them you go
to Alaska
Joe muted technical stuff this morning
sorry yeah
so I
did you say yes
unmute first and then say yes yes sorry
thank you representative Doucette
representative Elliott yes
yes
Baxter yes Pillsbury yes tutor yes Amy
yes Ames yes Southworth yes Malloy yes
Schamberg representative
Tucker yes go Marlo yes Laughlin
you're muted Tom
yes thank you Gordon yeah
hacking Phillips yes Murphy yes
chairman major yes
German major the final vote is 24 in
favor of retaining zero against
well the vote 24-0 the motion to retain
passes
thank you consent
it doesn't go on the calendar okay
um we have 13 more minutes so since we
have 13 more minutes we could probably
3.55
which
looks like God damn it it's fine
hmm
I'd like to go into House Executive
session on how to spell
355 relative dictino
and the uh
let me grab that
Mr chairman I've got a procedural
question yes why is representative Lang
voting
is replacing uh hold on one second
replacing represented early oh thank you
I missed that when we went around
and Alexander's replacing Mary Griffin
yes that I
um
okay house call 355 is an act relative
to Tino
do I hear emotions
Mr chairman I make a motion to retain
house bill 355.
and that's representative
was that
yes
okay the Motions to retain House Bill
355 representative Tudor do I have a
second
oh second representative brahmi
foreign
is to retain House Bill 355 made by
representative second by representative
Brandy discussion
saying no discussion and I'm going to
ask to click to call the roll
we thank you Mr chair to begin the roll
call Vote with Representative Patrick
abrami yes
representative Joe Alexander
yes
representative Lang yes
representative Ober yes
first team the clerk votes yes Doucette
yes
yes thank you representative yes
Nunes yes Baxter yes Pillsbury yes
scooter yes all me yes Ames yes
Southworth yes Malloy yes Hamburg
representative Schaumburg vote Yes
Tucker yes go Marlo yes golfman
representative Tom Laughlin
a good time down is not voting unless we
see him
representative gorg yes
hacking Phillips yeah Murphy yes
representative or chairman major yes
Mr chair the vote is 23 to nothing with
one member not voting
um representative Tom laughman I vote I
vote Yes also made it
um the vote is 24 to nothing in favor of
the motion to retain well I've been 24
to nothing motion on House Bill 365 to
retain it passes
foreign
Bill house bill 364.
make the motion to retain uh
Representative brummy makes the most
entertained
Ronnie makes a motion of retain on House
Bill 364. first team will second that
verse 10 seconds
speak to my motion when you're ready
represent uh Mr chair representative
Brownlee I want to speak to him also yes
this is uh representative rulery's Bell
representative ruler he realizes that
this bill needs some work on uh even
though he's not here today he did say
yesterday that he's willing to uh
uh see this bill be retained
um there's a lot a lot of work needs to
be done uh as we talked this bill
through there were more and more federal
tax codes
that came into play as to which of the
which of the Charities would fall under
this raffle bill
um we need to need to clarify all that
not enough time now to do it so let's
let's retain it and uh and do it right
I think if we limit the number my my
personal feeling is that I I don't have
a problem with certain Charities being
able to play raffle Raffles but uh we
just if the Bill's not ready and uh and
I don't think uh representative ulery
felt he had enough time to to fix the
bill or for the committee to fix the
bill uh before deadline so thank you
any further discussion
thank you Mr chair to begin the roll
call vote on HB 364 the motion is
retained representative abrami yes
representative Alexander yes Nang
representative Lang
yes thank you representative Elber yes
it's our first Dean votes yes do set yes
Elliott
Bob unmute yes sorry Fred
just a suggestion everyone should unmute
themselves continue the roll call Vote
with jinigian
representative yes Tucker yes go Marlo
yes loffman
yes
porg yes hacking Phillips yes Murphy yes
German major yes
Mr chair the vote is 24 to nothing in
favor to retain
Hospital
364 was voted out as 24-0 to retain
thank you
we have five minutes left
so
we can do House Bill 565
um
House Bill 565 and act establishing a
committee to study charitable gaming
do I
hear a motion
I'd like to make a motion
representative Tucker
your motion
uh who who suddenly like to make a
motion
I did
okay
would you make a motion yes that uh
HB 565 uh
ought to pass
representative Tucker moves HP 6 565
after pass do we have a second
representative
seconded by representative Bromley
discussion
any discussion on the motion of what to
pass on 565.
saying that I still close to call the
role
thank you Mr chair all right gang let's
get this done without incident
let's begin with uh representative
abrami yes representative Alexander
yes Lang that's over yes clerk votes yes
to set yes Elliott yes
Canadian yes Nunes yes Baxter yes
Pillsbury yes Hooter yes Ami yes Ames
yes Southworth yes Malloy yes Schamberg
Community Tom
yum
all right hang on hang on hang on a
minute I gotta get the video now am I on
okay representative yes
thank you sir representative Tucker yes
go Marlo yesman
yeah gorg yes back in Phillips yes
Murphy yes German major yes Mr chair the
vote is 24 to nothing for HB 565 the
motion of all to pass carries
okay I I was supposed 565 passes with a
vote of 24-0 without objection you go on
the consent calendar anybody object
I see no objections I'll go on the
consent calendar
thank you
now for previous bills
we need to
exact not right now would be cacr1 cacr2
Hospital 10 once we find out what we
really want to do with that
house built 15 we have some
clarification on that from the dra but
we'll get into that on the second
oh we're going to have work session on
all the bills that we've heard
on the second and the third
of March
there's no time for work sessions next
week because we're doing revenues on the
23rd the 24th and 25th is going to be
session days
and then the following Tuesday is the
second
the other bill
is
we need to do more work on House Bill
210.
568 and 626.
so those are all of our those that we've
heard and we haven't
accept them yet
so right on time
here I've moved the sponsor into the
panel
before we start Mr chair yes
representative is the is there are there
going to be any other bills today that
we're going to exec other than the ones
that we're hearing that we may exec no
okay thank you
so
um
take that intelligence and
friends
and we thank representative Alexander
and representative lion
okay next is a house bill 252.
House Bill 252
is an act creating a committee to study
the creation of a program giving
employer tax
on business taxes in exchange for
providing stipends for child care needs
to employees
we have
one person that has signed up we have
representative Fenton here to present
his bill
right I haven't mentioned that yet
yeah he he missed the sign up timeline I
I see in addition to the sponsor we have
one that have signed up to support it
and then we have 24 that have signed up
to oppose it
so miss representative Fenton
been the prime sponsor
you're on
absolutely can you folks hear me
yes that's great uh thank you Mr
chairman and ladies and gentlemen the
committee uh I did miss out my sign up
deadline uh my wife and I had a baby
last week so congratulations thank you
thank you things have been a little
crazy and that's why I'm also not on
video because the bags under my eyes are
reaching the floor so was it your first
no this is our second we've uh we have a
two-year-old so things have been even
more crazy
but all happy and healthy so thank you
for asking
um yeah so I am I am representative
Donovan Fenton I represent Keane
um here today to talk to you about HB
252 which is creating a committee to
study the creation of a program giving
employers tax credits on business taxes
in exchange for providing statements for
child care needs to employees and that
is a mouthful so I will keep this brief
um because we're talking about study
committee uh the reason for this bill um
I came up with this um because I lost
employees during covid-19 we have a
family business and I'm proud to say we
didn't lose anyone because business was
slow and we need to get rid of them but
because we lost them uh because they had
to stay at home and take care of their
kids who were out of school
um daycares clothes schools closed so
one parent had to stay home uh you know
this pandemic has really changed how we
look at everything you know parents are
home now and so are kids uh they can't
juggle being on a zoom call while trying
to get their child bogged onto their
math class and so we need to get them
back to work you know they're the
backbone of New Hampshire's economy
um you know options for funding Child
Care Limited which is why business tax
credits could be a potential Avenue for
bolstering this field I know several
credits already exists for the BBT such
as cdfa Investments non-profits
scholarships so this could fall in line
um you know this would be a study
committee uh to study this issue to see
if it's feasible to implement and with
that I'll take any questions questions
or yeah
questions from the committee
uh representative
thank you Mr chairman representative
Fenton did you consider any other way
than uh cutting further into our
business taxes to do this
through studying how much it would cost
to do it yeah absolutely and
representative thank you for the
question so the reason I chose kind of
the business tax is um you know the the
way I look at it is you know the
marginal rate of the BPT is now what's
affecting our economy right now I think
Child Care remote learning is what the
issue is you know and I think it will
just pay itself forward if we have
employers who can hire more uh employees
you know because a lot of people can't
work right now because of their children
and I think New Hampshire has the 12th
highest child care costs in the nation
so I think this would really supplement
that and get more people back to work
if that answers your question yes thanks
uh thank you representative for your
testimony
um do you know of any New Hampshire
companies that are doing this
voluntarily
representative thank you for the
question uh no I don't um and I think I
stated this earlier you know I have a
family business we actually employ 200
full-time and part-time people uh and we
actually looked into this before and we
just you know we can't make it feasible
because the exuberant costs of child
care right now and it's more difficult
with parents at home
um who sometimes need to hire a
babysitter and you know I'm not saying
that babysitting should be part of this
program but that's why a study committee
would be fantastic to see if it's
feasible for someone who is zooming at
home you know to hire a babysitter and
that could be supplemented as well
you
any further questions
representative
thank you Mr chairman
my question is I want to get this
correct now we give the employer uh tax
credits and the employer a page for
babysitting is that correct
representative Elliot thanks for the
question uh yes and no
um couch if so I used babysitting as
just an example but that wouldn't
necessarily be part of this program I
was more stating that you know uh
working has changed since the pandemic
so you know some some parents are
working from home and unfortunately they
can't uh bring their child to daycare
because a lot of them aren't operating
right now and some might need to hire a
babysitter for you know 30 minutes while
they're on a zoom call presenting a bill
per se
um but you know that that could be a
feasible option not babysitting but more
online of uh for child care needs for
school needs
thank you
further questions
representative yes I I'm very interested
that someone has come up with um
a bill addresses a very current problem
but it seems to be rather narrowly
constructed
as I think representative almie pointed
out that it just talked about a credit
arrangement
would you be interested in broadening
the wording so that this could also take
on the study of what has happened from
this pandemic who has been affected what
kind of businesses and what kind of
employees
particularly gender related uh where I
gather there's more of a problem
and
then see where it comes out
rather than coming up with a particular
solution to what has turned out to be a
major problem
representative Tucker yes absolutely
thank you for your question
um and I I would absolutely be open to
broadening this bill I think I really
want to get across so the main reason
for this is I want this bill to be
advantageous for both the employer and
the employee you know we're asking
um you know the employers to step up but
we need help with an investment from
that tax credit so the reason I chose
that was because I always wanted to make
it so that businesses weren't being hurt
but I absolutely agree that you know we
could broaden this bill
great well I'm sure there are lots of
people who could help you who have been
deeply involved in this obviously you
have too with your family business but I
I hope that you can do that because I I
really think that having uh while we all
remember what it's been like you know a
year or two from now it will the
pandemic will fade in our memories
and we have a problem
is there a question about no okay
further questions yeah Mr chair I have
one I'm unable to raise my hand
digitally
okay
so uh thank you for visiting our
committee today representative currently
if a business elects to give a stipend
to an employee they get that as a tax
deduction
and what what you're what you want to
study a little bit more in depth is
elevating that deduction to a credit is
that correct
representative yes thank you for it so
yeah as you said that you are correct a
stipend would be
um as it stands now is a deductible but
was changed to a credit
but again this is a study committee that
can be changed and as uh representative
Tucker said earlier you know we have the
ability to mold this
um
thank you
okay any further questions
of Representative
send none of them is going to call upon
a will Stewart who's a lobbyist
and representing Statewide New Hampshire
and he supports the bill
Mr Stewart thank you Mr chairman members
of the committee uh my name again is
Will Stewart I'm the executive director
of stay work play New Hampshire which if
you're not familiar with it is a
Statewide non-profit whose mission is to
attract and retain more young people
here in New Hampshire and uh we are as
you mentioned in support of this bill
you know because we believe that you
know more options for creating you know
more child care availability
um is critical to attracting and
retaining more young people here in the
state and that is very much necessary
um and critical to the future of the
state right now as you might be aware
New Hampshire is the second oldest state
in the country with one of the lowest
unemployment rates even you know during
covid on top of this we're the number
one exporter of high school graduates
seeking a four-year degree with some 62
percent of these young people leaving
the state every year some of them come
back but many of them don't
um you know in short New Hampshire needs
all the people we can get in general and
all the young people we can get in
particular our businesses need workers
and customers our towns need volunteer
board members and our non-profits
churches and Civic clubs all need
volunteers to accomplish their vital
missions without which our communities
just can't function
and you know about three years ago State
play We commissioned this survey to
collect data on why young people stay in
and leave New Hampshire and one of the
reasons we found was uh you know Child
Care available your lack of child care
availability and affordability
um you know as uh representative Fenton
mentioned you know this you know has you
know profound impact impacts on
Workforce and uh you know so again
statework play is in support of studying
this issue to come up with um you know
as many solutions as we can to address
this critical issue to our Workforce and
to make sure that we can attract and
retain the young talent that we need
here in New Hampshire so thank you
well thank you for your testimony Mr
Stewart questions from the committee
representative
thank you Mr chairman Mr Stewart on
have this this bill focuses only on tax
credits we currently the situation that
we have is that the finance committee
puts in the budget uh not enough money
to help with the child care situation in
the state but it does put some money in
and wouldn't it be better if this
committee broadened itself out to
looking at the most efficient way for
the state of of on doing more for the
child care crisis that we have
rather than just focusing on reducing
the uh general fund money that can be
used for things like child care but also
substance abuse and a lot of other
things that businesses need thank you
thank you representative for the uh for
the question and uh you know I will say
that you know I think that uh the state
should be you know there are lots of
things that can and should you know be
done to address this issue you this uh
proposal to study is is one of those you
know there's there's no Silver Bullet
it's a uh a complex issue uh to be sure
if there were an easy fix it would have
been fixed a long time ago right
um I think this is you know one
potential option uh there are certainly
others and I would encourage uh the
legislature to explore all such Avenues
to address this uh this very real
Workforce Development uh challenge
further questions
saying none we thank you Mr Stewart
thank you
the sign up sheet
had
24 that have signed up opposed to this
they're all members of the public except
elected official Sherry Frost
representative Frost is Norm yeah
uh Norm uh this is
252.
232 yeah no you read the wrong column
there I think it's uh most of them
signed up in support 24 in support oh
I'm sorry yep you're right in support
the no is not testifying right thank you
thank you
so the 24th signed up in support
sorry about that but they're not
testifying right you just look at the
wrong column it's okay
and I apologize for that
um
anybody else who is specified for our
events
I don't see anything
okay then I'm going to close the public
hearing on House Bill 252.
Mr chairman yes
I would like permission to to try to
Fashion an amendment that would make
this a study of the most efficient way
of dealing with this problem
in terms of funding
um okay
what is your study Amendment going to be
that'll be different from this this is
creating
a committee to study
it's creating a committee only to look
at tax credits on the business taxes in
order to to promote Child Care needs to
employees I do not know and I think
people on the finance committee could
help us figure out on
which way that way or the way they're
doing now or some other way that the
child care people can think of on would
be the the best way to direct funding
towards this really important need
and uh why don't you go ahead and get
your amendments
thank you when we meet on the second of
March we should be a work session day
you can discuss it
representative may I yeah
I'll do respect to my colleague
representative uh Army doesn't this take
this out of the realm of ways and means
what you're thinking
your Amendment
thank you
it does but if we're going to try to
make our government efficient enough to
live with low taxes we have to look at
these kinds of things
and uh
thank you okay I'll back up I will see
what the amendment says thank you thank
[Music]
you
all right anything else on
oppose of public hearing on House Bill
252.
uh the next school is scheduled for 10
30 so we're going to take a break until
10 30.
so don't go away just
mute your video
and audio
foreign
thank you
okay being 10 30.
I'm going to open the public hearing on
House Bill 346.
which is an act relative funding so the
funding source for the domestic violence
program fund
the sponsor representative Edwards
it is yours now to present your bill for
the Canadian
uh thank you this is uh representative
Jess Edwards I represent District Four
of Rockingham County that's Auburn
Chester and Sandown today I'm coming to
you
um to many of you as a former colleague
on ways and means uh those of you who I
had the pleasure to serve with last term
uh have heard much of what I have to say
today uh often enough to where you could
probably provide my introduction
testimony for me but to to keep you
interested and and to reflect my new
learning over the past many months
um I've got some some new and improved
things I want to talk about today
um for for those of you who received my
written testimony it's a it's a Word
document and on page
two of that written testimony is a very
simple little picture that is sort of
the quintessential you know a picture is
worth a thousand words in this case it
may be worth more than a thousand words
but
um
I'm gonna I'm gonna assume you've looked
at my testimony and you may recall the
that that graphic that I'll now describe
you know it it basically shows that
under the current law we have uh two
streams of money that are flowing
directly into uh our dedicated funds for
domestic violence programs uh the two
are a well-established stream from the
marriage licenses which seems to be a a
pretty predictable Revenue stream
although it's not cut in stone it's it's
got a a historical behavior that looks
to add about three hundred and sixty
thousand dollars uh in the next budget
the
um New stream is from the marriage
officiate license that we passed last
term and because it's new we don't
really have a history with it but upon
looking at other states around us and
and and how those streams have come in
we've had smart people put together
their best guesstimate that a hundred
and twenty two thousand will be brought
from that so if you take the 360 for
marriage license and accept 122 is a
good estimate for
um
um the marriage officiate uh that that
comes in at
482 thousand dollars that's the amount
that the governor's budget
reflects
um I provided an abstract of the
governor's budget in my written
testimony as well so that those of you
who like to see hard things have it in
front of you when you want to look at it
so what my bill does and more
importantly my amendment I really want
you to focus on my Amendment and not the
underlying bill because the amendment
improves it so much
what it does is it takes the uncertainty
out of the funding stream that goes into
the dedicated fund it takes the
uncertainty out because
I'm committing to you that the general
fund will put that full 482 thousand
dollars that's reflected in the
governor's budget into the dedicated
fund
and the money that comes from the
license fees will instead go to the
general fund so for the purposes of the
general fund it's a wash
and and and why is it wash a wash or why
is it worth doing the wash
I I think it's worth doing the wash
because we have solid we have dirtied
the the reputation of the institution of
marriage because we have a state policy
we've
pretended that the act of marriage
creates a or has a Nexus to the creation
of additional domestic violence
and I think that Nexus that Assumption
of a Nexus is wrong and it's insulting
uh and that the better way to go is to
find a more relevant more correct Nexus
for a set of special funds to be
dedicated
so what I would like us to do is to take
this two-year budget as a transition
that is the chair of division three
Finance I have some influence over
ensuring that this domestic violence
fund is fully paid for that's my
commitment to you it's a commitment in
writing it's a commitment to to you
personally that I will hold
um the governor's budget request of 482
000 that money will go under the
dedicated fund and for people who want
to know why this dedicated fund funding
is so important it's because
General funds lapse at the end of every
budget the dedicated fund is a
non-lapsing account and by putting money
into this non-lapsing account it will
give the managers of the domestic
violence program the more flexibility to
ensure continuous flow of the contracts
right now as I understand it there are
very few contracts that this money pays
for I believe it may be just one uh to a
particular uh organization here in New
Hampshire and I want to assure the
leadership of that Coalition that I am
committing here to make sure that that
dedicated fund is fully funded
so
um
I think those are my key points uh I say
a lot more in my written testimony so I
would commend that to you one one thing
I would add is I I've also been
appointed to the governor's Commission
on alcohol and drug abuse prevention
treatment and recovery and as I'm
getting up to speed on what that
committee does one of the things it does
is it recommends the authorizations of
funds under RSA 12 dash Juliet colon 3.
and it authorizes the fund to invest in
recovery services for individuals and
families affected by alcohol and drug
abuse
I believe that that may be a much more
appropriate long-term place to to find
the funding into long into the future
for the domestic violence program
dedicated fund
so
um so with that I'll I'll take questions
if there are any well thank you for your
testimony representative Edwards the
first one is Roxanna Bromley
I'm user Pat you're gonna have to unmute
thank you Mr chair uh thank you
representative Edwards um it's always
good to hear from you
so I'm actually glad you did this but I
want to make sure I understand
um did you have any
um influence in on the governor and him
putting this in his budget this way
I would love to pretend the governor
calls me and and asks for my advice but
he he forgot to call me on this one sir
okay so but you know the straight answer
is no no sir I didn't make sure I
understand then
um you're saying that uh so the budget
the the the budget that was forwarded to
the to finance from the governor doesn't
have does not have this money in it or
or does it have this money in it already
it absolutely does and that's why I
included the abstract in your written
testimony that I provided it shows the
uh uh the the cut out of the governor's
budget and and in the governor's budget
you'll see 482
000 and change like something like 650
bucks four four eight two six five two
something like that that's the
governor's projection for
dedicated funds and there are only two
sources of dedicated funds one is the
marriage officiate license excuse me the
marriage license where if you look at it
historically it's it it brings in
anywhere from three hundred and fifty
thousand dollars to to 365
000 and and so I just for estimation
personal purposes I put 360. and so that
means that the balance from the
governor's estimate and
um and historical is about a hundred and
twenty two thousand which I assume is
related to their estimates for the
marriage officiate uh slice of the
license
okay just a follow-up please follow up
so so okay so I follow what's going on
and basically instead of the
uh these well first of all let's start
with the marriage license fifty dollar
marriage license the clerk of the Town
clerkeeps seven dollars the rest was
going to
um the special fund
instead it's going to go to the general
fund
and then the thing we passed last year
the special officiant license which is
85 dollars for out of state people
coming in to officiate a marriage
of which five dollars still goes to the
Secretary of State but the remainder
goes and now instead of the special fund
it goes into the general fund is that
correct
this is your Amendment that's under
current law yes sir
and my recommendation is to have that
money put into the general fund directly
your amendment has both of those now
instead of going to the Department of
Human Services special fund
RSA 173 B15 it goes into the general
fund of both of those the the 43 dollars
per marriage license goes into the
general fund and the
uh eighty dollar eighty dollars for the
special officiant goes into the uh
general fund so basically it's it's it's
going to the general fund
and and then what what what has to what
you're saying is for finance is going to
have to rely you're gonna have to rely
on finance every budget cycle to make
sure it continues to fund
this
um domestic violence is that correct I
want to uh explore your use of the word
every budget cycle every I am saying uh
this this is a bridge to use General
funds for this next budget
but I will come back in August to OLS so
that we can look at it in January I will
find a better source of dedicated funds
and so I'll be back next year I hope
with another bill to identify a source
of dedicated funds so that we no longer
rely on this the Nexus of marriage but
we rely on a different Nexus and right
now my
best guess is to use alcohol commission
money in the budget years that follow
the one we're about to to do
so so I need a bridge
of one budget to to get us in the
long-term position and I would ask that
you trust that I mean I really intend to
do this okay so thank you I'll let
others uh that's now thank you
representative software uh thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question
um could you say a little bit more about
the power of your Amendment
um the reason I ask is my experience is
once things get to finance it gets very
tricky about what gets cut what gets
approved and so on and I really want
certainty for domestic violence programs
and that's what they've had of course in
the past so it's hard for me to kind of
trust in a broad sense uh what might
happen in the future thank you
so thank you for the question and it's I
think it's a it's a fair one
um so far Finance has received four
bills that uh were explicitly intended
to have money from the general fund
appropriated to a range of different
um activities and uh the approach of the
finance committee has been to discuss
them we view them all fairly positively
in general I think but and we're going
to retain them we're going to retain
them so that we can see what ways and
means you may know that Ways and Means
has to provide us with the with the
revenue estimate
and so when we get the revenue estimate
we can start taking a look at the
governor's budget and hb2 much more
closely to determine how much room we
have to maneuver but I'm I'm I I
understand that as the chair of division
three Finance
which controls the DHHS budget as a
component Committee of Finance overall I
understand that historically
the the chair of that division three has
had a lot of influence on making sure
that some funds are are protected and
others may be not protected and I am
giving you 100 percent my commitment
representative Southward that I will
protect the general funds sourcing of
the total amount of the governor's
budget into this dedicated fund you have
that as my deepest most solemn promise
that may not mean much to you but it
means a lot to me
does that answer your question sir
you're on mute
yes thank you I
I just again really want to know more
about
um the power of an amendment like this
in finance and I think you know it
really depends on what's happening with
the economy and a lot of other factors
from my perspective and I don't really
want domestic violence uh funding at
risk because of what's happening in
other areas thank you yes sir if I could
just um Mr chair could I just add
something on to that sure
um okay given that this is a wash
through the general funds meaning that
under current law the the the 482
000 approximately was intended to go
direct directly to the direct the
dedicated fund given that in my
Amendment I'm just saying let's put that
money into the general funds and have
the general funds do the appropriation
from there I I think that's a very solid
argument that most people in finance
would go okay well it's new money going
to an Old Source you know let's let's
let's let's keep the governor's promise
on this
representative
Susan you you're murdered
Susan you're muted
representative you're muted
somebody
completely muted me
um well we were gone
um
representative Edwards I understand I I
fully believe in your
assumption that your assumption is that
you can control this process in finance
and in Senate Finance on I have seen a
lot of cases when a division Chief has
been overruled by the uh
the head of Finance because of the needs
of of the state elsewhere
on
and I have certainly and you you have
too seen times when the Senate Finance
rearranged
the deck chairs and then just sat on
them and said we're not moving
so
I am very concerned the reason that it
is a dedicated fund was to provide
certainty for domestic violence when
they had been getting less and more and
less and more on at at different times
and it does support as you know and I
know that you have been following
domestic violence problems on that on
there are a lot of agencies depending on
this and a lot of people depending on
those agencies around the state
on
I also am worried as to if you protected
this and the governor put in his budget
the money that was estimated for the
dedicated fund to come from the
dedicated fund so on I'm worried that
you might in order to protect this have
to get rid of the child care allocation
which we've just been talking about how
important Child Care is to the economy
of the state on or a number of other
things that that
we take care of
and I'm also worried because on we could
have a relapse because of covet variance
into another recession that the governor
would have to be cutting and last time
he cut every new program in order to
produce the Surplus that he got
um and
or reduce the deficit quite a lot
so
I'm I'm quite worried about taking this
out of dedicated fund status I know that
you have a major
personal moral objection to this the way
it is funded
now but I wish that you could
delay a little and come with your
Alternate Source which if it is from the
alcohol commission is probably going to
take money away from substance abuse
treatment and prevention which is at
least has been the the
reason for the alcohol Commission which
has been going since then Senator Gordon
got it set up 20 years 25 years ago
something like that thank you
do you have what do you feel you really
feel that you can control us into the
future
so
um I I will admit that I I don't know
what I don't know and I have not
experienced the opportunity to be on
finance or to be a chair of division
three so this is very new I think your
concerns are are are are valid for the
most part I have had a couple of good
discussions with the chair of Finance to
let him know what I was doing and what I
was thinking and that I can assure you
that the chair of Finance is not
surprised by this and is a voiced
support for this endeavor
um uh I I think I would go back to uh
one thing you said about the alcohol
commission and I have so much to learn
there but it's my understanding that uh
five percent of the net profits were
supposed to go
be available for a range of expenses and
uh it's in less than those five
percentage points have been brought over
under the alcohol commission and that a
greater percentage of that five
percentage points is meant to come over
so it's like that fund is getting some
new money and I'm I am not
um
I would want to just point out to you
that
um I'm not creating a new line or a new
justification to spend money from that
commission RSA 12 dash Juliet colon 3
already says that money can be spent on
Recovery Services for individuals and
families affected by alcohol and drug
abuse
so so the responding to the horrors of
Domestic and Sexual Violence with the
alcohol money I think is perfectly in
line with the original intent and the
legislative words of that statute so so
that's not that's not a hard fight it's
sir everything's a fight but I that's
not a hard one I don't think
foreign
thank you Mr chair
um representative Edwards I
know all the respect again
um why we why do we even have to deal
with this bill because it sounds like
it's going to be an hb2
uh it sounds like the governor in hb2 is
making these proposals
uh to have the money come out of the
general fund and have these marriage
license fees going into the general fund
uh so even if we pass this bill
the Senate has to pass it to become law
and in the meantime you and finance have
to produce your budget by the first week
of April
so and you'll be voting on in the floor
we'll be voting on the floor on on the
budget
um so I'm assuming that before this
becomes law it's going to be in the
budget that's going to we're going to be
voting on
so why do we need to act on this bill
in all the respect I'm really trying to
understand
I appreciate what you're trying to do
here just so you know
um but this is more of a procedural
question than anything else
so if I led you to believe that the
governor's budget
is going to say in hb2 that the these
dedicated fund sources for marriage will
go
uh to the general fund then I misspoke
we've not seen hp2 and I don't I have no
reason to think that the governor will
do what this amendment does okay then I
missed it totally I thought I'm sure I
miscommunicated
that the governor's budget the budget
hb1
has 400 and whatever 82
in the general fund out of the general
fund to pay for domestic violence is
that was I mistaken in hearing that I I
was mistaken if I said that I I to
clarify if you look at the abstract of
the governor's budget it shows
um
let me call it up just to make sure I
don't miss state
foreign
item for agency income there is a number
there
459 dollars for each of the two fiscal
years
that is a number that I'm sure is made
up of two things I'm it's a guess but
I'm pretty sure
one is the long-standing historic
funding source from marriage licenses
Plus
a guesstimate of how much money will
come in under the marriage officiate
Bill those are dedicated funds sources
under the governor's hb2 or it'll
probably be silent on it since it's
already existing law uh but but what I'm
proposing is to is to not go forward
under current law I want this amendment
to change the current law so that those
two sources go into the general fund and
the general fund for one budget term
pays for
pays into that dedicated fund
and that one budget will give me time to
come back and say Here's a much better
source
for funding this domestic violence uh
appropriation as a as a childhood
Survivor of domestic violence I want
these accounts funded fully I think
these are vital programs
but in our family the act of marriage
saved our family
it was the abuse of alcohol that caused
the havoc and the chaos and so
I react
probably
more viscerally than most people when I
look to see that as state policy
New Hampshire is in the position of
offending the institution of marriage
while letting alcohol abuse off
scot-free and I want to fix that because
I believe the messages that we send as a
state legislature at some level matter
okay representative Edwards I I you know
I agreed with you last term in the term
before on this issue uh but uh but I I'm
just it's a procedural question we do
have the governor's budget uh person in
with us tomorrow
will Probe on this one to see what hit
the intention of the of the governor was
about the 482 million uh a thousand
dollars a year uh going forward over you
know for the next two years anyway
yes sir go from there I think we'll have
a little more knowledge after tomorrow's
meeting with the governor's budget
fellow uh director
represented an engine and
thank you Mr chairman
um representative Edwards in in
principle I uh this uh uh bill is new to
me being new to Ways and Means so in
general I look at this I I agree with
what you're trying to accomplish here it
makes sense not to make it look like
marriage is is the offending situation
in the alcohol fund does make sense to
me
um why not to I've heard a lot of
uncertainty expressed from different
Representatives
um as and we none of us can predict the
future so why not come back with an
amendment on this where you where you
introduce you know kind of swap out so
to speak the marriage
um fee with an alcohol fee and that way
you don't have to go through multiple
steps to get there and you can eliminate
the uncertainty that many are concerned
with
that's a good question
um because you were not in Ways and
Means last term you were spared the two
or three times where I I held forth on
this issue uh in a in front of a very
patient committee
um in August uh when we were had our
bill period opened
um I had no clue if I was going to get
reelected let alone uh get the
assignments that I've received so I put
a bill in in August to keep this issue
alive
and it was after my assignments and
after some committee meetings where I
thought oh man there's a lot cleaner way
to do this than what my underlying Bill
36 346 did so I submitted an amendment
that would make 346 cleaner and easier
and get rid of an extraneous idea now
you're if you are as a committee uh
wanting to kill 346 and the amendment
with it
I'll just keep coming back I'll figure
out more I'll I I will work this until
I'm convinced that I've been able to
convince enough people that this is a is
a good and right thing to do and that
and that procedurally it's all okay
thank you
representative Tucker
yes I I too find that the idea of fixing
something that's not broken
is very hard to understand what we do
know is that it appears that the
incidences of domestic violence have
risen during the pandemic as people uh
are forced to spend a lot more time with
each other which sometimes unfortunately
does lead to violence and abuse of
various kinds whether physical or verbal
psychological
this doesn't seem to be the time to be
changing funding or leaving a bridge
into an unknown we know that domestic
violence is a problem right now that
it's a rising problem in the pandemic I
don't believe this is the time to have a
change let's leave well enough alone
make sure that this program has funding
that there's no temptation
once it's in the general fund not to
spend it because
it we are facing many uncertainties
let's leave certainty in the funding of
domestic violence if you're able to
identify a better Source another year
I think that's fine then we can just one
question
well I want to know how you react to
that
I react by saying that a major part of
what you said in your question to me is
not relevant to the amendment I've put
before you my Amendment fully 100
funds domestic violence programs uh I
think in a way it's better than the
current law because the current law
assumes approximately 122 000 for
marriage officiates uh licenses that we
don't know if that's coming in and I'm
offering you a guarantee of fully
funding this at the governor's level and
so I just don't want anyone to miss here
and think that I want anything to do
with cutting domestic violence programs
because I do not I want them fully
funded so um so to your other point
though about it not being broken that's
a difference of value systems my value
system says it's broken yours does not
um
and that's that's okay that's why you
know we all get elected to come
represent our people
thank you you're absolute names
thank you
um
good morning representative Edwards
uh so this question relates to the
suggestion that this program domestic
violence program
uh might better be funded from the
alcohol
fund
and um
my question to you is
is this do you have information on the
proportion of domestic violence
that is occasioned by
alcohol abuse or more broadly substance
abuse
so so that's a great question and I
spent a lot of time on the national and
local websites trying to look for
statistics of different types in a
statistic I wanted to validate was what
I heard in Health and Human Services two
terms ago that 70 percent seven zero
percent of all domestic violence occurs
between unmarried Partners unfortunately
on the website they only use the term of
our intimate partners and make no effort
to distinguish between marriage and and
unmarried
domesticated couples so so so that was
once that I really wanted to bring in
here that's kind of buried and not
exposed on the websites the the but to
your specific question uh I also was
looking to see
um if there was sort of a breakdown of
factors that lead to domestic violence
you know in my mind I was thinking well
maybe there's a pie chart out there
somewhere that says you know X percent
is related to drug abuse y percent is
related to illegal drug abuse uh
another percent is related to
um you know couples not having good role
models to follow in in their teen years
you know I but but there are those I
can't find those statistics and when I I
when I got called about two weeks ago
from a national lobbyist I asked her for
help finding these statistics and she
said she'd call me back and and that
just hasn't happened yet so I I uh I
don't know I I can just tell you in my
personal experience
um both as a young man and as a company
commander in the army that the domestic
violence that I've seen is
predominantly related to uh uh an
incident following alcohol abuse
and um and I don't have the stats to
back it up other than life experience so
um so I'm sorry I can't do better than
that representative Banks
okay let's leave it there thank you
representative
representative major I think you'd
representative Edwards for taking my
questions
um I do happen to have a pie chart of uh
victims relationships to their abuser uh
the the largest category is the spouse
category and
um I think we should acknowledge that
there are other relationships beside
besides intimate
um
where the abusers are not the intimate
partner they can be the father mother
brother sister cousin
roommate
um yeah so there's a lot of different
categories but the largest category is
the spouse
um
my question though is do you know of any
complaints from people that are
purchasing their marriage license about
where they're forty three dollars is
going
no but I think that's because people
have no clue and I would love it if you
would please provide your statistics
with me because I I'm telling you I have
been trying for a year to get my hands
on statistics that would I will answer
that I'll email that too it would be
great I'd also be interested in who
emailed it to you but but that's the
different issue well it's the
the New Hampshire Coalition of domestic
violence and I believe there's an
attendee that wants to speak as well
maybe they could raise their hand
thank you
so I would add that I've not been
contacted by the Coalition and I did I
did do an Outreach effort through a
friend of a friend
um I I wanted to talk to them before
today
okay
um representative element
thank you on basically I just wanted to
clarify something for representative
abrami representative Edwards uh isn't
it true that in the governor's budget
that uh 500 and whatever 400 and
whatever it is uh is uh going to show up
as other funds
mainly that is coming from dedicated
funds and his budget contains all
spending whether it's from dedicated
funds or other or the highway fund or
whatever
yes ma'am and I I've tried to agree with
that two or three times and the graphic
is posted in my written testimony
thank you I I know I just wanted to make
sure that uh it was understood by the
committee
any further questions for
representative Edwards
I don't see any thank you for
representative Edwards thank you Mr
chair and I will continue to listen in
case there are further questions for me
later thank you okay the next is a
Sandra summer who is a member of the
public who wishes to testify in our
position
and I don't see a Sandra Plummer on the
attendees list
however
I believe Pamela English
is an attendee and wanted to testify but
she'll have to raise her hand if that's
the case
okay you do not see a Sandra Plum I do
not no
okay
the one who just mentioned uh she just
raised her hand her name is Pamela
English and he's from the New Hampshire
Coalition against domestic violence
uh see you on the list
she was not on the list he raised her
hand oh boy okay Mr chairman
I think if you asked Pamela kalig she
would tell you that Sandra Plummer has
had a emergency and could not come today
and I believe that Pamela English is
substituting
thank you for the clarification
uh Pamela anyway
good morning Mr chair uh this is Pamela
English can you hear me
yes are you substituting for Sandra
um I'm sorry but I'm not aware of who
Sandra Plummer is I am substituting for
our executive director Lynn Chalet who
cannot be here today because her father
just passed away okay and you
in opposition or supporting I'm in
opposition sir okay thank you
so good morning Mr chair and members of
the committee I am the administrative
director of the New Hampshire Coalition
against Domestic and Sexual Violence
um the Coalition is an umbrella agency
for 13 community-based questions in New
Hampshire who provide free and
confidential services to nearly 15 000
survivors
of sexual and domestic violence every
year
um I thank you again but I'm also uh
sorry to hear that representative
Edwards has experienced domestic
violence in his household growing up
this unfortunately is common in our
state programs work every day to protect
victims and children who are far too
often trapped in homes with abuse we're
also incredibly grateful to
representative Edwards for his
commitment to providing funding to these
life-saving programs
just a little about the domestic
violence prevention program it was
created in 1981 by the legislature and
guaranteed a funding source for domestic
violence programs
the program has supported tens of
thousands of victims
of domestic violence over the last 40
years moreover nearly 30 other states
provide domestic violence funding
through marriage license fees
as we talked about currently 43 dollars
from marriage licenses and eighty
dollars from the new special officiant
licensed goes towards the domestic
violence prevention program
and that will bring nearly five hundred
thousand dollars annually that crisis
centers can rely on from year to year
this is also a tax-free way to fund
these valuable services
and although this
alternative funding source for domestic
violence Services the suggested funding
source lacks stability and I'll get to
more about the amendment but originally
there was parking tickets and fines
they're not a stable source for domestic
violence funding nor is it an adequate
replacement for what currently is
provided
according to the fiscal note these
alternative funding sources would cause
programs to experience an almost total
loss of funding as a result of the bill
so the domestic violence prevention
program provides funding for core
services
for victims and their children across
New Hampshire these are critical
life-saving services including emergency
shelter
services for traumatized children
exposed to domestic violence the
operation of our 24-hour hotlines and
allows for trained and confidential
domestic violence Advocates to accompany
victims to court proceedings and to
hospital
visits so it's critical centers can
respond with the services they need and
with a commitment to keeping victims and
their children safe unfunded programs
should never be the reason a Survivor is
denied access to safety
as you all acknowledged earlier we
remain under an unprecedented Global
pandemic that's created even more
barriers for victims of abuse and their
children
over the last year our crisis Advocates
reported that incidents of domestic
violence had escalated
to alarmingly lethal levels an increased
need for survivors to receive immediate
interventions just to stay alive
crisis centers experienced a 39 percent
increase in calls to 24-Hour hotlines
receiving nearly 100
000 calls for survivors in 2020. that's
in New Hampshire
so Advocates across the state report
that the needs of survivors have become
more complex as a direct result of the
pandemic
without the support of our services many
victims and their children would remain
in
would remain trapped in abusive and
dangerous homes
crisis centers have had to turn away 3
500 adults and 2 000 children
due to lack of capacity from 2017
2020.
I wanted to talk a little bit about the
relationship between a marriage between
marriage and domestic violence
so we understand there's some concerns
expressed by the sponsor over the
funding source and the connection
between domestic violence and marriage
in preparation for this hearing we were
able to analyze data from the last five
years which we routinely use in Grant
reports
according to Statewide data collected by
our crisis centers over the last five
years 27 percent
of victims of domestic violence served
by our programs were in spousal
relationships I believe representative
Jenny I'm sorry I don't remember her
last name Grimaldo maybe
talked about
how it was the highest relationship type
for reported domestic violence compared
to all of the other relationship types
and that is true from what we see from
our data
uh moreover we know that marriage does
not cause domestic violence but it does
make it a lot harder for some victims to
leave because of legal obligations or
religious commitment children and Joint
assets and debt
and it's not surprising that we see more
married people seeking help at our
crisis centers it's much easier to leave
a relationship when you don't have those
obligations
similarly alcohol does not cause abuse
but it can make domestic violence worse
Firearms do not cause domestic violence
but they do make the situation far more
lethal
domestic violence is a choice
most abusers do not threaten to kill or
slap their bosses or the police officer
who pulls them over they can manage
their anger they just choose to use
violence and threats as a tactic to
control and exert power over their
partners and kids
so we urge this committee to vote HB 346
inexpedient to legislate and ensure that
our state's crisis centers maintain this
stable source of funding
Mr chairman
speaking in addition to the sponsors
proposed amendment today the state does
not provide adequate funding for
domestic violence Services through the
state budget and the funding levels
shifted dramatically over the past few
budget Cycles
the Coalition and all 13 crisis centers
would prefer to have this dedicated
source of funding over these dollars
being issued through the general fund
because we've seen Stark fluctuations in
the general fund appropriation over the
years including one year in recent
history when the legislature
appropriated little more than two
thousand dollars
to domestic violence programming shared
by 13 member programs crisis centers
serving 15
000 15 000 victims that year
so while we are extraordinary grateful
we are grateful for representative
edwards's commitment to increasing
general fund dollars as well as the
extraordinary leadership of governor
sununu and the current legislature's
commitment to funding Services we cannot
ensure that this will be the will of
your legislatures as it has not been in
the past
victims of crime could certainly use an
increase in general fund Appropriations
but in addition to our general funding
through the marriages which has been
used successfully for the past 40 years
it is vital that crisis centers have
this funding source that they can rely
on
thank you so very much and I'm very
happy to have take any questions
would you supply the committee a copy of
your testimony
yes I shall the other question is on my
list here I have you listed as opposed
would you testifying as opposed
but it listed as not testifying
it was that a mistake or did you
actually put down you're not going to
testify
uh it's quite possible that originally
we put me down as not testifying but
again our our executive director
uh my boss Lynn Chalet who was going to
testify when was unable to do so because
the um her father passed away yesterday
okay that explains it thank you thank
you would provide us that testimony it
would be appreciated
I I intend to email that to you shortly
representative
uh thank you Mr chairman and uh thank
you for taking my question
um a couple of things beyond the 500 000
um I was curious in Broad terms what
your other funding were uh sources were
and also
um are any of these things eligible for
matching funds thank you
thank you very much for your question
representative
um we do have some federal funding
through the violence against women act
and through the victims crime Act
and through the federal family Vines
prevention and services Act
but uh you mentioned match
representative and
those Federal sources require a match in
order us for us to receive them and uh
they're as much as 25 of the federal
funds and we use the domestic Advanced
prevention program because it is state
general fund dollars as well as the
marriage license fees
uh for the match
for those programs so that's another
very strong argument to keep marriage
license fees uh as a stable source of
funding for the domestic violence
prevention program
thank you a quick follow-up follow-up so
just an estimate of your total expenses
when you add in all the others
full expenses
foolishing
this
annually yes
uh it's where since covid we've gotten
several other funds to assist with that
we're about 10 million dollars
so that
um is uh
so 500 000 is State five hundred
thousand other
I'm sorry I'm not sure I understand the
question representative was so was a
million year total including the 500 000
from the state
from the state it's
a million five
okay thank you
did you ask that your total expenses
were 10 million or one million
I'm sorry are you asking representative
yeah I'm asking representative
yes thank you all of the coalitions
funding both federal and state and
private is
um about 10 million but State funding is
only uh approximately 2 million
and that's with covid
correct and before covert what was the
funding
total funding or just State funding
before October
yes that was about seven and a half
million okay thank you are you all set
representative
yes thank you that I was confused
thank you Mr chairman thank you Mr Miss
English for your testimony just a
curiosity question you know we've heard
anecdotally that many marriages have
been put on hold because of the virus
um how's this impacted the revenues uh
coming through these two programs
well representative I don't believe that
the Coalition is able to see the number
of marriage licenses that were granted
over the last several years and I I
think that I would have to say I also
know that anecdotally and I'm not aware
of data I get to
to substantiate that so I apologize for
not having the answer that's fine okay
appreciate it thank you
representative
thank you Mr chairman uh and thank you
for taking my question I just uh
personal curiosity you mentioned a
couple times there's 13 crisis centers
could you tell me Tell the committee
where in the state those centers are
located
yes I certainly can
um they are located in Berlin
I'm going to do this from Messi so uh
Berlin Littleton Plymouth Lebanon
uh Hanover no Claremont I'm sorry
Claremont some of them have uh
satellite offices
um Portsmouth
Nashua Manchester Concord Laconia
and Conway I might have gotten 13. Keen
did I when you provide us your other
testimonies if you provide us that list
that would be great
I certainly can we can provide you a map
that shows you a map of New Hampshire
that shows you the catchment areas of
the crisis centers
thank you thank you so much
any further questions of Mrs English
I don't see any uh reps in the
spillsburg
thank you Mr chairman um this English
uh I did understand you to be defending
the logic of uh drawing for marriage
licenses
but I think your emphasis was on the
need for dedicated funds so my question
is if we retained this
and an amendment was brought forward
that made a direct substitution
of a reliable source of dedicated funds
would you then drop your opposition
thank you for your question
representative
I don't know that we would only because
as representative Tucker and I believe
Almy
mentioned this has been a stable source
of funding for almost 40 years
and we would be concerned on a couple of
levels that it could take away funding
from other very needed services in the
in New Hampshire such as for instance
the opioid addiction that would come
from the drug and alcohol fund and those
types of um very important services so
um we would be hesitant on that note and
it is a small amount and is spread out
among 15 000 victims per year but it is
an amount that we can pretty much count
on and I think that we would certainly
look at whatever the committees or the
legislature would offer
but I don't think I could say
definitively today representative that
we would not be in opposition of a
change my goodness we've experienced a
lot of change over the last year haven't
we all
mm-hmm thank you I understand your
concern
thank you very much
I have further questions from the
committee
and the attendees
I don't see any hands raised
now the sign up sheet
because
18 signed up in support of the bill
and 121 signed up in opposition to the
bill
the lesson but it's available
any further questions or comments on how
to build 3 46.
if not then I'm going to close the
hearing on 346 and we will be discussing
it again when we meet
on March 2nd
let me just catch up my
we have three more bills but they're
scheduled for one o'clock 1 30 and 2
o'clock
I
the public hearing is over uh does
anybody have any questions in general
if not then we will see you all back at
one o'clock just mute your video and
your audio
thank you representative major yes uh
you did get my email that I may be late
yes I did okay thank you
thank you
let's explore
yes
foreign
should have
at least 25
.
and it is one o'clock
so we know this afternoon
yes we are there's no one signed up to
speak
uh
except for the speaker uh except for the
sponsor
Francisco is heron as representative
Harrington here
um geez did I see that uh yes I'm sorry
okay
I'm going to open the public hearing on
House Bill 400
and act relative to the collection of
sales tax
of foreign jurisdiction by New Hampshire
businesses representative Harrington
um
Daniel Mr chairman can you hear me yes
we can okay but this is a pretty
straightforward bill I think most
members are familiar with the Wayfair
decision that was made a few years ago
by the Supreme Court it was a case
brought by the state of South Dakota
when all the way the Supreme Court it
was a 5-4 decision and basically they
changed the idea of physical presence in
order to collect uh sales tax so for
example uh if some business in New
Hampshire in the past who had no
physical presence let's say in
California sold items to a resident of
California over the Internet there was
no uh need to collect any sales tax uh
by the company in New Hampshire and
remit that to California
this um Supreme Court decision the
Wayfair decision changed that like I say
in a 5-4 decision they came up with this
virtual presence standard in which
Justice Kennedy was the big purveyor of
uh he he was the one who was really
pushing this and basically what it comes
down to now is that
if someone has a business in New
Hampshire and they sell that same
product to somebody in California they
have to collect the sales tax from the
buyer and then remit that to the state
of California
and for those who aren't familiar with
it there it's a lot more complicated
than that statement just sounds what I
just said because there's somewhere in
the vicinity of 12 000 different sales
tax in United States uh different rates
some places cities have them imposed on
top of the state some products have them
uh some other products that are very
similar don't
um if you look at Massachusetts for
example if you buy I think it's clothing
up to 200 is no tax but over 200 there
is a tax uh certain things like
charcoals considered a fuel so it's not
taxed uh there's there's all these
varieties and it's almost impossible for
anyone to keep up with it without I
guess you'd have to hire some outside
company whose expertise was doing that
but my point is and the reason I put
this forward was as most you aware a
couple of years ago there was a lot of
activity around this and it was meetings
and so forth and but nothing really
happened what has happened and since
then is a lot of the states have
followed the so-called South Dakota
example which
it could be a little bit off on the
numbers here but I think they say if
this company in say New Hampshire if you
do get make less than 200 Sales to
individuals from South Dakota in a given
year and the total value is less than
one hundred thousand dollars then you
don't have to bother with the tax but
nevertheless if you go over those
amounts you do some states have followed
that other states are still working on
it but the reason I put this forward is
because I mean the bill is pretty pretty
straightforward it says nor the
inhabitants of this state controllable
by any other laws then those to which
they or the representative body have
given consent therefore New Hampshire
business no New Hampshire business
retailer should be required to collect
sales or use tax for a foreign
government or provide any information
the facilitation of collecting these tax
and let's collection is mandated by the
Congress of the United States in
accordance with the Commerce Clause
article one section A Clause 3 United
States Constitution the Attorney General
of the State of New Hampshire so defend
this law in all jurisdictions where it's
challenged and
this puts forward the New Hampshire
Constitution and I might also add that
like I said Kennedy Justice Kennedy was
one of the pr he was the person pushing
this and he's gone obviously uh justice
Ginsburg is gone so of the five justices
who voted in favor of it uh is only
three left and I obviously don't know
how the new justices would vote on it
but I would think it would be difficult
if this was to get to the Supreme Court
for the U.S Supreme Court to rule that
the New Hampshire Constitution was that
was enacted prior to the Federal
Constitution was unconstitutional
and I just don't see them doing that and
that's the reason for putting in the uh
the Attorney General
shall defend the law because I don't
want them going after individual
companies and and try to take them I
don't even know what court they take
them to maybe federal court or state
court in another state but the fact is
our constitution is very very clear on
this and we never the people of New
Hampshire never elected the Supreme
Court nor did they elect the
representatives from South uh Dakota or
Massachusetts or California or any other
state so our constitution says they will
not be required to follow those laws and
the only case where it would come in is
under the Federal Constitution which
clearly gives the power to regulate
interstate trade under the Commerce
Clause to Congress of the United States
so I think this is what our constitution
says it just simply codifies it I'll be
willing to take any questions thank you
for your testimony represent Harrington
um representative Bronte
oh thank you Mr chair thank you
representative Harrington uh good seeing
good hearing from you
so you know we spent a lot of time on
this on this issue over two sessions uh
two two years worth
um
there was a joint committee with the
Senate uh we had the governor's Council
involved in drafting language
the goal of what we came out with which
is in place now
is that
yes yes the only way we can resolve this
is going back to the Supreme Court
but the trick is to be able to get the
Supreme Court to take the case
and the council that we got was you got
to be careful about that you just can't
say well we disagree with the Supreme
Court and and and
think they're going to take the case
so uh yes this has never been ruled on
under the Commerce Clause
uh that's probably the Avenue eventually
but it's our understanding that from um
talking to dra just the other day uh for
everybody
there have not been that many
inquiries the way our bill our current
law works now is that
companies that are being reached uh out
by from other states asking them to
collect the the tax
um we have not gotten many referrals
from other states or other companies
about that
so uh I just want to make sure you you
aware of that that it's it's been pretty
calm since since our work of a couple of
years ago uh are you aware of that yes
yes I am aware of that I think probably
a lot of that has to do with the covid
situation that that's everything else
has been put on the back burner so I'd
kind of like to take advantage of that
and I realized what was done there and
that we haven't seen a big push but I
think once things start to get back to
normal some things won't and that's I
think this huge increase in the use of
the internet and these other states are
just going to look out there and just
say there's too many tax dollars we're
losing and I think you'll see that uh
that process accelerating as far as
getting to the Supreme Court I agree uh
it could be a long process but again I'm
an engineer not a lawyer so this is my
best thoughts and that's that by having
the Attorney General defend it they
could have the state of New Hampshire
challenge you know if there was business
a in New Hampshire being taken to court
by the state of California
then the state of New Hampshire could
step in and challenge the state of
California which would then get primary
jurisdiction to the Supreme Court if
it's one state going after another state
that would be I guess the most uh
efficient way to get there if that can
be done but I realized it's never easy
going through the courts but I just
think it gives a venue we have a
constitution that's been there for you
know over 200 years it's very very clear
what it says this is an ambiguous and I
think as representatives from the state
of New Hampshire we ought to be
defending that Constitution and saying
we will protect our companies uh under
that under that provision of the
Constitution which says you can't do it
to them
all right well I'll let this go for now
but uh we may be hearing from the
attorney general who's in charge of this
now
uh hopefully and if we do have a hearing
I'll make you aware of of that hearing
or work session on this bill in which he
would testify if he's not testifying
today yeah well thank you very much for
that I appreciate because if you know
how to get in touch with someone at the
Attorney General's office you must have
much better connection than I do because
I've been trying for a while on this
issue and other issues and I send emails
and get no response and if you call you
simply get a tape saying
um our mailboxes fill go away and
there's no way to even leave a message
so if you can get through to them let me
know
well our goal is to get an update as to
where we're at okay but we we heard
through the dra that uh
that that the amount of activity is
minimal uh what's going on in this so
I'll let that go uh thank you enough
questions thank you representative Ames
thank you
um and picking up on representative
abrami's uh
points and background information
um
first we did enact substantial
legislation after
some hiccups along the road uh have
involving a special session once during
the summer and then we tried again and
we got through it and uh reformed the
bill and and put in place legislation to
set the Attorney General sort of in a
uh position where
um that office would monitor what's
going on and uh recommend actions or
perhaps even take legal actions
unilaterally for the state
um and we set up a commission
uh to uh review what was going on the
Attorney General was part of that the
Attorney General's designee uh I was on
it I don't know whether representative
Romney was there I don't remember
um and uh and it was chaired by Senator
Morse
and covet got in the way
so uh it never it never reached the
point of making the recommendations so
far as I know uh that were called for by
the statute and now it's expired and it
would make I wonder uh representative
Harrington if it might make more sense
rather than just sort of go for
the the bottom line as your bill does it
would make more sense to revive that
commission I'm not recommending this I'm
really asking
um so that the key actors the attorney
general who you've had a hard time
getting in touch with for example
and uh Senate leaders and house leaders
could uh
[Music]
hear the latest information what's going
on Nationwide and in New Hampshire
and take considered action based on that
and as you know I think uh well as you
know the
uh
this kind of legal action is is costly
and for a small state like New Hampshire
to take the lead
um uh is a step that has to be based on
on something really sound
um so my question is uh is about taking
a different route than your bill
oh thank you for your question I I would
suggest that we take multiple routes in
that I guess the best way to describe at
least in my opinion what was done uh
over that special session and so forth
is we put hurdles up that made it more
difficult for a another state to force
someone to collect sales tax business in
New Hampshire we didn't prevent it we
just made it more difficult they hit a
jump through a few Hoops here and file
things here and do this but my proposal
is not a hurdle it's a roadblock it
would stop them say you can't do it and
I'll still come back always to the oath
that we all took which says we're
supposed to defend and uphold the
Constitution this is what the
Constitution says and we should be
defending and upholding it that doesn't
mean we can't take alternate approaches
as well I mean we hit him with
everything we got as far as I'm
concerned if there's other ways to to
make it more difficult for doing it
let's go for it but I think we have that
obligation to uphold the rights of the
people of New Hampshire
okay I'll leave it there thank you
you're welcome represent Harrington uh
representative Ames idea of
of the commission would you be against
that
nope
I'm sorry
I lost I don't know if anyone can hear
me but I can't hear you okay all right
again uh let me make sure my heart goes
on now I can hear you now I can hear you
okay
representative Ames suggestion of having
a commission reenacted would you object
to um having this changed into a
commission
well I mean if it would be a question of
and we have to be realistic about things
obviously if it's if it's a question of
not getting this passed or changing it
to a commission I would certainly
consider that as a as a way to go down
that road I think we need to be doing we
need to be doing something and if we
have a commission that would be
certainly better than having just have
this bill killed so I mean I'm going to
be a realist I've been around long
enough Norm you know that you gotta if
there's no sense in just going in with
dreams because that gets you nowhere
thank you representative Elliott uh yes
uh thank you Mr chairman uh my thought
is that uh there is no need for this
bill uh that that I'm aware of and
there's no motion uh from representative
Harrington uh is it your intention that
we ought to practice today or uh
because I don't think it'll pass uh I'm
sorry I thought this was just a public
hearing and not the executives first
questions representative Elliott
say that again if you have a question
yes what is what is representative
Harrington emotion I know it's a public
hearing but what's what's going to be
his motion to pass this
well I would it doesn't make that motion
it's the committee that makes
I'm just here as the bill sponsor I
don't have the authority to make a
motion one way or the other in ways and
means oh okay I get it okay
thank you Mr chairman representative
thank you Mr chairman
representative Harrington we went
through in a awful lot of testimony and
we worked very closely with Governor
sanu's legal counsel who is an extremely
capable individual
and with the Attorney General's office
they all assured us that we were not
going to be able to get
something like this in without being
sued and losing in federal court unless
we want to secede from the United States
uh
I realize you think that maybe scotus
would change their minds but on
wouldn't it
on the commission was not working when
it died because on the person in charge
of it was from the Senate was the
original author of the bill and
um
didn't could not get people to show up
from the attorney the attorney general's
office frequently had problems with
showing up because the time that was
picked was sometime when they were in
Trials on and on
we were not getting frequent
participation from uh the dra did come
the business and economic Affairs did
not quite frequently on
but we did get information as you said
that nobody uh very very few if any
you I believe it was if any people had
actually complained that they had been
taxed by this we did know that places
are already paying and have been paying
before this all blew up
um
to avoid having to do lawsuits with
other states
so would you
um a commission that started from the
house probably could get further with
this if and my so my question is
would you mind us turning it into a
commission again
well thank you for the question and let
me just let me answer it in two parts I
still think you know you said that uh
it wouldn't be upheld in court but I
think we still have an obligation
because it's a right to find in our
Constitution and we ought to be
defending that that's that's one of the
jobs that we have uh is to uphold the
rights that are defined in the New
Hampshire state constitution and this is
clearly defined in there and this uh the
Supreme Court really is a violation of
that so I think we have an obligation to
do that but having said that as I said
to the chairman one has to be realistic
too and to have this uh you know get
voted down 15 to 5 or whatever uh and go
nowhere is not accomplishing anything so
if it's in the wisdom of the committee
they think in order for this to move
forward we can re-establish that
commission I could I could live with
that it's not my first preference but
it's certainly better than having this
the bill just to feed it and go away
because I do realize it's been hasn't
been happening that much but I think
come this summer next fall things get
back to normal and the the uh Amazon
trucks are still rolling all all over
the world like they are now there's
going to be much more push on these
other states to start collecting that
sales tax
any other questions from the committee
foreign
Harrington oh thank you Mr chairman we
have I have only one person that signed
up that's a Glenn bracket
who represent a lobbyists in the
working people the New Hampshire ASL CIO
their opposition
and they do not want to testify
once again anybody else wish to testify
for or against House Bill 400
attendees
nobody can hear 10 days
I would say so
I'm going to say something
I just said no representative major no
attendees have their hands raised all
right then I'm going to close the public
hearing on House Bill 400.
the next bill is scheduled for 1 30. it
is 1 21
uh could we be out of water if we
discussed the cost of 400 now
as a committee
it isn't it hasn't been
putting a calendar as a recession
although my my opinion is that uh this
just brought up Wayfarer again
uh and that you know maybe we should
here hopefully before we we vote on this
bill
that we can get the AG I know we have
the name of the specific person that we
have to contact
to come and explain exactly where we are
right now just as an update to us okay
nothing to do with the bill in a way but
indirectly yes with the bill yeah well
that makes a lot of sense to me that's a
good suggestion yeah I'll get a hold of
it
I think you'd have to be sure to to get
him during a time he was available
that's been one of the big problems they
go off to court all the time
I'll get for my for my former call and
see if he's available on the second
because he's the one who really want to
talk to
the governor's Council
no no no he's the attorney that oh okay
no I think I think uh to clarify John
farmalla uh at that time and I think
think still although I don't know for
sure was the governor's legal counsel
right and and he was uh and from the
attorney general's side there were
various people that came to talk with us
at one point bill hardinger was there
wearing uh some kind of consultant hat
to it to the attorney general and uh
very much involved in the redrafting of
the bill so I think uh farnella yes but
he's probably not engaged right now on
this issue and there is uh probably an
Assistant Attorney General who has the
assignment I'm sure he has the right
person
I think Carolyn Lear sent us a note
um uh on a name she sent us a name of
somebody from that she deals with all
the time uh from the AJ's office that
she thinks is the right person so I I
printed that email out but I'll I'll
talk to you offline uh about it okay
so I just like to point out that one of
the things that was in what we passed
was that the dra and the AGS office
would be cooperating on finding people
who were upset at being being taxed in
this way and certainly when they're
being taxed retroactively it's very
difficult
we can review that work session on the
second and see where we want to proceed
based upon their important
Norman's patigan
um yeah I found an email
um the name of the attorney Samuel
Garland she said yes that we speak
that's the same one as last time okay
yes
all right she's been talking to him
about this and other things on and off
so
I'd like to point out that there has
been on all of the states that have
started collecting this and most of them
have have experienced large increases in
their sales tax revenues
and
there is no way they're going to give
that up without a fight
that's right
we have six more minutes
you have a hand up
uh that's in hack and Phillips yes
Master chair I just wanted to bring up
um a side comment about this given the
fact that the work session is scheduled
for the 2nd of March I
probably have a professional conflict
that day where all I too will be in
court and I just wanted to weigh in with
a little bit of my concern that uh you
know the cost of litigation at the
Supreme Court level is exorbitant and
I'm not sure that that is a prudent
fiscal determination to make in such a
year where we're already worried about a
health care crisis as well as you know
budget revenues and I just I'm not sure
that that is a prudent
um cause of action for the state to be
endeavoring at this time
thank you for your input
uh anybody else may I just follow up by
saying beyond the fiscal concerns I am
deeply concerned about the
constitutionality and bringing this case
though
um on its merits alone I also have
concerns but I think from a budgetary
perspective
um I just wanted to weigh in both there
you won't be available in a second
sure yeah
it sounds like
you should hear
what the attorney has to say
yes absolutely
any other comments
this is an important issue for the state
so
we've been fighting this tour
many many years
ten representative major has been
fighting it I think for about 18 years
I joined him since 2000 years ago
I I knew all the
people involved but some of them are
passed away
representativeian has his hand up
[Music]
is that
you have to realize there's only five
states that aren't that doesn't have a
sales tax
and they're all five small states
as far as going to Congress to get
legislation to help us out that isn't
going to happen
well the biggest majority we have is two
senators I mean who could have 10
Senators out of 90.
but in the house
out of 535 members
we may have a dozen
when
[Music]
is to somehow get it through the course
and three of those states have allowed
their big cities to collect sales taxes
yes
so we're unique because we're the only
state without a broad-based tax income
or sales so
anyway it is oops not quite yet ready I
got one more another hand up now okay
Pat not me uh John uh John yeah oh yeah
I'm sorry about that John no no problem
um I guess first a question I mean if is
what I'm understanding from the Lost
side of this are people saying that if
we pass this it'll automatically trigger
The Challenge and wind up in the Supreme
Court
and notice that's a question for a
lawyer in the group I mean is that what
people are saying that if we pass this
we're automatically going to be
challenged and it's going to go to
Supreme Court
how about
names or
hey you're asking whether Mr
Harrington's
suggestion
would end us up in the Supreme Court
well yeah so let me first weigh in and
then maybe dick you can weigh in I know
you're real close to this as well yeah
yeah it would certainly it would
certainly trigger something by the other
states against us and it is going to be
uh but that's not the way we wanted it
to happen we wanted to pick our battle
if there was ever to be a battle in a
situation where we actually had a chance
of winning
and doing it this way it wasn't it was a
lot of conversation around this
and that our approach we felt that the
approach that's in place right now is
the approach
um we fend it off it seems okay maybe
it's because of the virus I don't know
so far we've fended off these states uh
they're not they're not banging their
doors down but I think I think we got to
do this in a more like we did we came up
with a very systematic way of
approaching this we've got the question
the question was if we pass this will we
end up with a supreme court no I I guess
my response would be that uh
one never knows um this would be um
you know on his face
a rejection of federal Authority that
probably wouldn't stand anyway a
challenge
could well be would likely be successful
I would say but the fact that it's on
the St our statute books just sitting
there it doesn't necessarily mean that
it will lead to litigation
um but if there was a company that
refused to pay
the uh tax of California say or whatever
uh like Wayfair did
um then you've got a case you've got uh
harm you've got the uh a real case or
controversy is it's
put in the law that provides a basis for
legal action and review
so I I I would doubt that just having it
on our books would uh by itself
lead to something
so it almost sounds like there's no way
for the State of New Hampshire to
protect our businesses from this I mean
even if we said we'll fight for any
businesses get sued
um we're still going to end up in at the
Supreme Court potentially and lose
I mean we might win I I shouldn't have
said it categorically who knows you know
as someone pointed out as a different
Supreme Court than it was I think
representative Harrington pointed that
out it's different different memberships
so you never know uh and you never know
whether justices will rethink the
situation the Constitutional law is a
moving Target
we might have enough when based on the
Commerce Clause
to all the Supreme Court did was it it
sent it sent it back down to the South
Carolina at South Carolina South Dakota
courts to deal with again
I think if I remember correctly
representative Ames I think that's what
happened that is what happened and then
the South Dakota courts vacated the case
right they said there's nothing more to
argue about yeah so that was that was
the end of that
could I just quickly add in on we
of what we were going after was the
Supreme Court set up a number of things
as recommendations essentially in their
decision both the people who voted
against and the people who voted for
said said if you're going to do this you
have to to put in a reasonable floor for
how much sales tax is being uh
being requested from one
state on that is you cannot go after a
state for under a thousand hundred
thousand dollars worth of sales that you
were taxing
on and they had a number of other
conditions like that in there that meant
that a small business
which has more trouble on dealing with
ten thousand jurisdictions of sales tax
places on was going to be protected
against being told that they have to to
figure out a way to to find out what
Oakland California resident who is
buying their pot
is is going to have to pay in sales tax
and figure out how to send it to Oakland
California
so I'm going to have to stop this yeah
thank you and open the public hearing on
House Bill 504
and House Bill 504 is an act relative to
the State education property tax and the
low and moderate income homeowners
property tax relief program
the prime sponsors Richard Ames and
represented Ames
thank you
um
and uh I am here to
to introduce House Bill 504 uh and it's
I feel privileged to be able to do so I
I want to note at the outset that I have
I think coming up to speak behind me uh
representative luno
uh who chair at the school funding
commission and uh William Arden who was
also a member of that commission and uh
Marjorie representative Porter
um and Jeff Mick Lynch of the school
funding commission so I'm going to try
to be quick although this is
[Music]
um and then allow time for these others
and there are others as well who I I
think want to speak I'm sure some will
be speaking in opposition so here we go
uh this bill is uh it really has has two
pieces to it that go together that
interrelate with one another one is a
reform of the Statewide education
property tax
and the other is a a reform of the
existing low to moderate income
homeowners property tax relief program
the two come together and I'll try to
explain how and there's a third feature
of it which calls for a study of certain
issues that aren't addressed immediately
by these two other reforms looking at
the bill if you looked at it but maybe I
should back up I sent I sent to all
members of ways and means
some documents I'm working off of those
documents here one was a three-page
documents
um the first page the three and a half
page document I think the first page is
key elements of House Bill 504
um the second page is a chart that shows
certain
impacts changes that result from it it
would result if this bill work to be
enacted and the last uh the page three
to four to the brief history of the
Statewide education property tax which
we colloquially refer to as swept
um and then I also sent to you a couple
of spreadsheets to try to illustrate the
impacts of these changes both the
property tax relief he's on the other uh
pace which is reform of swept
using both the towns that produce
so-called excess swept and I'll get to
that and another set of towns that I I
call it comparatory towns
that uh
uh will be impacted by these reforms in
different ways so you've got all those
materials I hope you got a chance to
look at them I'm not going to go through
them in detail right now obviously
because time doesn't permit it
um so two components to this bill swept
reform and property tax relief
pages one and two of the bill through to
line 27 on page two are the swept reform
changes Pages uh
to
to four
are The
Architects relief program reform changes
on the uh at the end of the bill is the
study committee
on the swept reform
first thing to say is there's no change
in this bill in the swept rate and the
Statewide education property tax rate
that's figured under current law as the
rate that will raise 360 million dollars
when applied against the taxable
Statewide property tax base which
excludes utilities and railroads
and it excludes those as we discussed I
think yesterday because those are taxed
by the state under two other taxes
so no change in the rate whatsoever the
rate floats
um and uh it's going down because it
takes less money less a lower rate
nowadays to raise 360 million dollars
than it used to take because property
values are going up
um so that's the rate
um a big change is that it remits the
bill would change where the swept
revenues go to it would still be
collected by the municipalities as it is
now they do the billing they'd receive a
warrant from the commissioner of the
Department of Revenue Administration
identifying the the amount of money that
they needed to raise by applying the tax
to their residents and uh and the rate
at an equalized level
um in this current year is down to 1.875
um it used to be uh it was 1.925 last
year and 2.060 the year before uh so the
the warrant comes in the uh local uh
local locality sends out the bill
collects the tax
um the tax comes in the money comes in
the money then is sent over by the
municipality to the school system
um
for school expenditures
um the uh under the law the purpose of
this tax is to raise money for the
adequate education formula funding and
in Most states it's it's not sufficient
to fully fund that so most school
districts receive the money from the
um from the municipality and then get
additional grants from the state from
the education trust fund to fill out the
adequacy commitment but there are 33
cities and towns today that where the
the swept amount exceeds
the education adequacy
calculated amount and those are the
so-called excess swept towns right now
that excess swept money for most of
these uh excess swept towns
um goes then towards other school
expense expenditures that are not uh
that are above the adequate education
amount
um there are there are 17 except
exceptions to that they're all uh
townships
um they receive uh the sweat they
collect the swept money just like uh
everybody else but they don't have any
education expenses these 17 that I'm
talking about and so in that case I
believe the money goes to offset other
municipal or County expenditures
um it's uh not for education at all
that's the excess swept
and under the bill that would no longer
be retained locally it would go all
Swift collections would go after
netting out the cost of collection and
the cost of promoting the property tax
relief program the
municipalities would send all of the
money to the Department of Revenue
Administration for deposit into the
education trust fund
so that's the change there that that the
money so sent
would include this excess sweat money
that I've just spoken about which totals
today about 26 million dollars
that's the swept reform side you turn to
the low and moderate homeowners property
tax relief program
um the ra would continue to administer
that program it's an existing program as
you probably all know
um administered today by the dra and the
dra would continue to administer it but
it would be a much more generous program
the
the relief
that would be available and I'll get to
that in a minute the formulas but the
the relief
would be
capped
at 25 million dollars Statewide
which is about equal to that 25 or 26
million dollar excess swept figure that
I mentioned uh just a few minutes ago or
a short time ago
um
and so the reform is fully paid for by
that excess swept money
um
the uh the relief is calculated by
applying
not just the Statewide education
property tax rate
but also the local school tax rate
combined
against uh the homo the homeowners
property value up to
but not above 150 150 000 the current
limit is a hundred thousand dollars
so we'd have a a rate that would be that
roughly two dollars of the swept
and further swept and uh then whatever
the local school tax rate is which
varies from in some mostly excess sweat
towns uh in the two dollar range all the
way up to um
well you know
um eighteen dollars sometimes more than
that for the education property
the local school tax side of the rate so
that entire rate would be applied
against 150 000
and the for the poorest
homeowner
the the result of that calculation would
be the relief available except that it
would be capped at one thousand dollars
for any particular claimant
um
and the eligibility for this relief the
numbers are in the bill I don't think I
can go through them but it would start
at twenty thousand dollars if you're
below twenty thousand dollars and you're
single and you have a home
um that's worth more than a hundred and
fifty thousand dollars the relief you'd
get would be
um would be the
the rate in your town times the hundred
and fifty thousand dollars would be a
hundred percent of that calculation
um if you had income above twenty
thousand dollars but we're below the uh
the top level of fifty five thousand
dollars you'd get some relief the relief
would go down as your income went up
basically a slope down of relief as your
income went up to the cutoff point for
that single person and there are
different numbers for
for married people
um substantial relief way above what's
currently available under the existing
formula under the existing formula the
maximum relief to that single person
would be
187.50
whereas in this this bill it would be
in the typical situation it would be
well above a thousand dollars would be
capped at a thousand dollars
um and the last uh notice that there is
a study committee that the Bill calls
for
um and that study committee will look at
some key some very important questions
one is
how to extend property relief
effectively to tenants
those rents effectively reflect
uh High property tax rates and we need
to figure that out and we need a
committee to help us figure that out
then there's uh the property tax
deferral program the the need and the
potential of setting up a good program
for those homeowners who are in
temporary circumstances and unable to
pay their bill but need need help
with a deferral system so we need to
figure that out as well and then the
third point is data information that we
and Ways and Means are acutely aware of
the need for in the in the property
realm dra has an enormous amount of
information on the on that has built up
over the years as they've been assigned
the responsibility of equalizing
property values across the state it's
the system is called Mosaic and uh and
we've looked I've looked closely at that
I've tried to use it
representative Luna who's the tech Guru
of
for the legislature I would say but
anyway certainly by the school funding
commission uh worked on it uh and uh
there were others that have tried but
one of the problems is the categories
aren't
particularly useful into which the uh
what you have to use are the categories
that are used in Mosaic and they don't
work very well
um so uh that's that's the bill as a
whole and I think I'd I'd leave it there
and hope that uh we can move quickly to
the other testifiers because I'm sure
their schedules are tight just as ours
are
representative thank you for your
testimony representing representative
Bryant uh Brumley yeah thank you Mr
chair thank you representative Ames um
this is indeed a complicated topic
uh I'm not an expert at all
but I live in the Portsmouth kind of
general area and they see in the local
papers
people in Portsmouth are calling this
return to donor towns because I think
they get hurt by this
can you can you is this tell me is this
going back to donor towns or not
um
I wasn't I wasn't present when you
uh when that donor Town controversy
erupted so uh so that's one point
um and
um I I use the phrase excess swept towns
rather than donor towns remember there's
no change in this bill in the rate
um so the uh we're not going up and in
this bill proposing
um an increased collection of money this
is a Statewide one thing I I failed to
mention is that this is a state tax
and it's subject to the Constitutional
Provisions regarding uniformity and
proportionality
um in the materials I gave you the last
page on the back of it there's an
extensive uh excerpt from a decision by
the New Hampshire Superior Court in the
Londonderry case
and just a quote from it that the court
in that case concluded that the uh the
bill before it which was enacted creates
a non-uniform tax rate and the court
finds that no constitutional
justification can be articulated to
permit the retention of those excess
funds by the property Rich
municipalities so I think the law says
this is the way it has to be
um now that's not I said that uh too
definitively as I said when we were
talking about Wayfair
um you never know with constitutional
law and how the court would come out but
I'd say the odds are that if this case
gets to the Supreme Court the excess
swept component of the law as it sits
today would be thrown out
um and the other thing to say is that uh
we're talking about a relatively small
amount of money and a very small
property rate change for uh the towns he
mentioned Sportsmen near you I think is
Newington
um rise not far away Newcastle is not
far away they're all excess swept towns
they also have a very significant
property tax base in my charts uh in my
chart
I show
the differences in in the median
valuation per pupil which is one way to
sort of compare from one town to the
next for the excess swept towns the
median valuation per pupil is 4.1
million dollars
for the cities and towns across the
state it's 1.1 million dollars huge
difference
um the amount of Education spending per
pupil that the excess sweat towns are
able to manage is 28 thousand dollars
per pupil for the towns across the state
it's about 17.5
17 500 per pupil
um big differences so uh and if you if
you took the the rates in those times
the property rates Town rates in those
excess sweat towns for school
expenditures and applied them against
the higher value recess
real estate that they have the real
estate there does cost more the actual
tax paid by the typical homeowner is
less than the actual tax paid by the
typical homeowner in say Claremont or
any other any number of other My Own
Town Jeffrey
um so uh perhaps the donor Town
controversy will be reignited by this I
hope not I hope that those towns will
see that it's a very small price that
they're they would pay for enabling a
property tax relief program that will
help their
their taxpayers as much as it helps
anybody else in the state and without
funding for this taxpayer relief program
it's not going to happen there's a
long-winded answer I'm sorry let me say
something about the donor time when we
passed the Statewide property tax back
in around 2000
it was an equalized value taxed on
property by the state and was supposed
to come into the state but what the
state did in their wisdom they made a
mistake what they said is quote you hold
on to it in the towns and you can use it
to pay
the share of adequacy
and then
that sounded good but then they found
out there was a number of times that
they raised more than that
and so that the town says uh
we
we don't want to give that away that
should be learned to us
it should have been going to the states
to provide
adequacy for everybody in the state
we try to change that back probably a
few years later and we've got cream
because everybody came out of the
woodwork this is a donor town it's not a
donut town but you that's what's going
to happen in this bill
goes through again so
but I'm I'm with you on that
uh the next one is you're also looking
around me
and I don't see any other questions so
we go on to the
amount last year
a large reporter I think representative
luno would be uh representative if he's
available
he's on
his represent oh his name is not yes
it is on the list and I just promoted
him it is okay is it
um
okay I'm here all right I just just uh
just was invited in so
um Mr chair is my audio okay
oh it's Luna not you know
[Laughter]
yes
are we good thank you very much Mr chair
and um and uh I just want to say it's uh
it's really great to see representative
Elliott we miss him in the education uh
committee so uh so nice to be uh be in
front of um you all uh albeit remote
this afternoon
um for the record my name's Dave luno
representing the people of Merrimack
County District 10 which is the town of
Hopkinton and the western part of uh
Concord
um as um as representative Ames uh said
I I chaired the school funding uh
commission which released its final
report back in December and will
actually be we've been we've invited all
um uh senators and representatives to a
briefing on this on on Monday next week
Monday afternoon next week it's noticed
in the calendar so anyway
um funding a public education continues
to be an issue for New Hampshire and the
subject of many Court decisions and
ongoing in cases the New Hampshire
Supreme Court has long held that the
responsibility to provide a
constitutionally adequate education
rests with the state the school funding
commission sees the objective of State
fiscal policy as to ensure sufficient
resources are available in every school
district in order for all students in
the state to have the opportunity for
constitutionally adequate education
well-designed fiscal policy should
consider the full costs of educating
students and recognize that fiscal
capacity varies significantly among
cities and towns and taxpayers and
thoughtful consideration of fiscal
policy for Education involves many
interlocking Parts all of which are
important in improving student and
taxpayer equity
the granite state is much to be proud of
when it comes to public education New
Hampshire is ranked third in the nation
by U.S news and World Report
K-12 education rank rankings calculated
across metrics of college readiness High
School graduation rates performance on
the nape math scores reading scores and
in preschool enrollment
of course averages don't tell the whole
story while New Hampshire's state
average student outcomes are among the
best in the country that's not true for
all school districts
average performance by District Falls
over a wide range with some districts
well above State average and others so
far below average that it calls into
question whether there was an
opportunity for any students in those
districts to access an adequate
education
New Hampshire's average total Public
School spending is in the top 20 percent
of all states
though it's total spending per pupil is
exceeded by several other New England
states however the portion of the total
spending comprised of state budget
support is the lowest of all states
while the while the low share of state
budget support for public schools can
contribute to student inequity across
the state it's not totally responsible
for the lack of student equity a
principal culprit for student inequity
is the method for allocating the state
budget resources between poorer and
wealthier districts
New Hampshire's current system of
funding is not working for large
segments of New Hampshire's students and
taxpayers
specifically communities with higher
poverty rates and lower property wealth
are doubly penalized under New
Hampshire's current system
s in these communities on average
receive fewer resources in the form of
funding than students in wealthier
communities
taxpayers in these communities do their
best to provide for their children often
levying higher local education property
taxes than residents of wealthier
communities
inequities also manifest themselves in
student outcomes the negative
relationship between districts
aggregated student outcomes and student
poverty
measured through through
free and reduced price lunch eligibility
is clear and strikingly linear
as District poverty rates increase
student outcomes decrease
New Hampshire has has significant
variation across municipalities and
equalized property valuations used to
generate the local Revenue necessary to
fund Municipal and school budgets
the most property poor districts have an
equalized property value per pupil of
less than four hundred thousand while
property wealthy districts have
equalized property valuations in the
millions of dollars property wealthy
districts generate more Revenue than
property poor districts per dollar of
property tax
a property tax rate
this means property poor districts have
higher tax rates in order to generate
the same revenue for schools as property
wealthy districts some property poor
districts have a local education
property tax rate of more than 20
dollars per thousand while some property
wealthy districts have an education
property tax rate of less than two
dollars per thousand
New Hampshire also has significant
variation in capacity to pay within
municipalities and the commission heard
substantial testimony to that effect for
example a homeowner and a property
wealthy District may live on a fixed
income and have limited Financial
Resources when compared to others who
live in that district and the state's
property tax relief program has outdated
eligibility requirements which limit its
use right now
compared to other states such as
Massachusetts New Hampshire's failure to
direct resources to districts with
limited fiscal capacity and provide
effective property tax relief programs
contributes significantly to student and
taxpayer inequities
the state property tax was introduced in
term the state property tax was
introduced in terms we would recognize
today uh back in 1919 had a rate of
three dollars and fifty cents per
thousand
over the years the state property taxed
for various classes of property has been
set at a rate between zero dollars per
thousand and six dollars and sixty cents
per thousand
in fy06 the legislature set a fixed
amount of 363 million dollars to be
raised by the state property tax and let
the rate float based on the amount to be
raised divided by the Statewide
equalized property valuation in FY 20
the equalized property tax rate was 1.93
per thousand
local education property taxes range
from about 52 cents per thousand uh in
Hearts location to twenty four dollars
and two cents per thousand in
Charlestown that means the owner of a
three hundred thousand dollar home in
one Community
which is pretty close to the state
average in in New Hampshire could pay
the same amount of uh same amount in
property taxes as the owner of the three
million dollar home in another community
nearly three quarters of New Hampshire
state and local dollars raised for
Education come from property tax revenue
in 2000 a commission to analyze the
economic impacts of various school
funding Revenue options was created by
then Governor Shaheen one one takeaway
from this 2000 report was that given the
complexity of administering the property
tax across hundreds of municipalities
New Hampshire would have to devote
considerably more resources to
administering the state property tax
than it does So currently back in 2000
so that the fairness of the tax does not
continue to be called into question or
challenged in court
but subsequently the constitutionally of
the Statewide education property tax was
called into question forming the basis
of the point
um you know styled is Sorel versus state
in New Hampshire this is back in 1999.
the Court ruled the state property tax
unconstitutional
because the state did not have systems
in place to provide equalized Statewide
property valuations outside of the local
property tax jurisdictions
following this decision the general
court made changes to how the state
property tax was collected and used
currently the pro State Property Tax is
collected locally and applied to the
municipality's total cost of an
education is determined by Statute if
the amount of the State Property Tax
collected exceeds this cost the state
issues an additional Grant to the
municipality in the amount of the excess
with the stipulation that it be used for
public education
by 2014 the dra had implemented a
comprehensive system called Mosaic to
evaluate property sales and develop
Equalization ratios for all
municipalities
substantial testimony was heard by the
commission attesting to the efficacy of
the system In fairness of equalized
valuations yep
um how much longer do you have
I can I can wrap this up but it this is
you know the the the
um I hate to bring yeah we have 10 other
people want to
okay so um if you want if you have it uh
as a document you could summarize
I'll certainly summarize it and send it
um uh I I did want to just make a make a
quick example here since we're talking
about excess swept and the state's
changes
um uh uh uh to to how uh the state
property tax is is is is is is done but
under under this bill House Bill 504
um
uh the the state property tax would be
collected locally and sent um in whole
to the uh to the state and just as an
example
um uh according to the doe data
portsmouth's cost of an adequate
education is about 10 million dollars
they raised 12 million from their State
Property Tax based on their their
valuation in order to raise that
difference two million dollar low two
million dollars through local property
taxes it would be 30 cents per thousand
of valuation so approximately three
hundred dollars on a one million dollar
home and don't get me wrong Mr chair 300
is a lot of money especially for people
living on fixed incomes or moderate
incomes but that's exactly who House
Bill 504 is designed to help and this
example is well within the scope of the
tax relief
I'll wrap it up there and uh and happy
to take any questions and to send um
send us into your Clerk
questions from the committee
representative Elliott
uh mute yourself unmute yourself
thank you Mr chairman I don't have a
question I wanted to say to David that I
miss him too thank you thank you very
much Bob
any other questions
the results
so we will go on to the next uh thank
you very much do you have a option
representative
yeah um I think uh bill ardinger would
be next
okay Miss adinger
do you remember him and
I am right now
and Mr Edinger said he would take three
minutes
hello
you're on thank you can you hear me okay
yes we can bill
very good
um thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee for the opportunity to testify
in support of this bill I will not be
long I want to say first uh for the
record my name is Bill ardinger I'm a
tax attorney at a local Law Firm wrath
young and Pignatelli our firm represents
uh many uh businesses and also uh
lobbies uh members of our firm Lobby I
am here not on behalf of any client but
on my own behalf anything I testify to I
would ask the committee to recognize is
my own opinion it is not the opinion of
any of our clients or
um of any other member of my firm I
would um like to say that I'm here
because I had the pleasure of serving as
a member of the education funding
commission with um representative Ames
representative luno and others uh I was
uh the designee or the appointment of
the governor of the state and it was a
very uh positive experience on this bill
which is about tax policy I support it
because I believe New Hampshire has not
taken the steps yet that other states
have taken to make the property tax
system fairer for all property taxpayers
who are subject to the tax the
commissions were concluded that the
property tax is like any tax nobody
wants to pay a tax but the property tax
is a good tax to this extent it is a
stable tax it provides resources that
have have been used to support the
construction of our Public School
Systems which is are the most important
assets of our public sector here and and
the the balance between a stable tax
base and supporting
um important public assets like our
common school system is is very good for
Education policy as a matter of tax
policy however the property tax has
flaws like every tax system the property
tax in sometimes applies to people of
low income who don't have the regular
cash flow that they can easily use to
pay their tax liability representative
Ames and House Bill 504 is puts a a
spotlight on improving and fixing
um this problem with our current
property Tech system the right way to
provide protections to low-income
taxpayers is a direct and robust rule
that applies directly to the intended
taxpayers the wrong way to provide
protections to low-income taxpayers is
to protect one whole Community under the
name which is a misnomer donor town
which then protects not just low-income
taxpayers in that Community but protects
very wealthy taxpayers who are perfectly
able to pay their fair share of the
obligation of supporting Municipal needs
and public schools I would like to say
that
um other aspects of this bill which is
to have the collection of the State
Property Tax
um all the proceeds remitted to the
State Treasury and then expended in
accordance with a fairer uh tax uh
distribution system that protects
communities like Claremont where I went
to high school and met my wife at
Stevens High School so many years ago uh
is is the right way to go in my view I
think it solves great risks that the
state currently faces under the current
system which effectively by leaving
dollars among wealthy and and poorer
taxpayers in particular towns
uh that raises a constitutional question
that at some point the state is likely
to face I think 504s House Bill 504's
effort to address that with a uh
remitting the proceeds like the meals
and rum Stacks that taxes collected
locally and remitted to the state that's
all this bill proposes and I think it is
a smart way to avoid a a problem in the
future that could arise when uh
taxpayers of of communities argue hey
how come that wealthy taxpayer in that
town is getting a tax break when we're
not and so with that knowing you have
other Witnesses I would just like to say
thank you uh to Chairman majors and
other members for the opportunity to
address the committee and I want to say
how much I appreciated working with
representative Ames and the leadership
of this commission and the whole team on
such an important issue like education
funding I look forward to working with
the legislature as it considers all
these issues going forward thank you sir
thank you Mr under any questions from
the committee
representative abrami
Mr chair I've got a quick question for
you for uh directly let me see your hand
back you're planning on having work
sessions on this bill correct
uh yes we will
and
uh Mr ardinger will you be available
when we have a work session to add some
clarity from your perspective you you
have a good way of uh
explaining things if you will I thank
you representative abrami and it's great
to see you and every member if the
committee would have me and
representative Ames would tolerate me a
little bit longer I would love to
participate in the work session
thank you thank you representative
yes also a quick question I'm glad that
you will be coming you would not come to
our committee for a long time on and but
I I would like to get your perspective
on how hard it's going to be to to solve
the issues of renters and tuition and a
number of other things that don't quite
do the job on on the formula that's
going not
not specifically for the low-income
dollars but in the renter case yes
and he couldn't respond to that in our
work session coming up
yes I would I first say to
representative Army I love this
committee when I was 18 years old I was
elected from Cornish and Croydon and
proudly served as a member of this
committee and and in this case I'm not
actually a lobbyist which makes me more
confident and comfortable coming before
you so and with you so I would also say
Yes
um other states have faced the renter
issue as representative Ames knows uh it
is not an easy issue but other states
have come up with some pretty clever
approaches and a great organization just
south of us in Cambridge the Lincoln
Land Institute has some great
representative Mommy I think I've been
to events there with you in the past uh
Daphne Kenyon and others there have some
good information on that that I think
would help the work session thank you
thank you very much okay
um
to get another view and and there's
Richard Stanton
and elect representative Stanton Like
That official representing himself who
opposes and said he needs five minutes
I don't see him in the attendees
I've looked for him
okay
that saves us five minutes
the next is representative Madre Porter
elected official from Hillsborough in
support and
needs three minutes
the last three minutes took about 10
minutes so
everybody takes
I am here can you hear me okay yes we
can okay a weird thing happened on my
computer I'm sorry for the delay thank
you Mr chair and members of the
committee and I will be brief I timed
myself at three minutes and eight
seconds for the record my name is
Marjorie Porter and I represent
Hillsborough district one and the towns
of Antrim Hillsboro in Windsor
representative Ames and luno and Mr
eardinger have done a fine job here
explaining the details of this bill and
all the ins and outs of finances that
your committee deals with so well but I
would like to bring it down now to the
local level and how passage of hb504
will provide real help to real people
specifically I want to talk about my
constituents here in Hillsboro
Hillsboro is a working class community
and is Frugal with its money
local boards are careful not to ask too
much and to keep annual budget increases
small
I served on the school board for a while
and I know how hard that board works to
do the best possible for the kids
without overburdening the taxpayers
the school district is sb2
most of the budgets passed in the last
10 years have been default level funded
budgets there are no frills
despite this we have one of the higher
tax rates in the state and homeowners
have seen their property taxes increase
year after year
personally the taxes on my modest ranch
style home on a small town lot increased
20 percent between 2016 and 2020.
I thought things might hold steady for
us this year
as our school tax rate actually
decreased by two dollars and forty cents
a thousand
but that was not to be the housing
market is strong and home values have
increased there was a reassessment
instead of going down property taxes
increased once again mine went up
another 320 dollars
of course the largest tax buy is the
local school taxes and overburdened
taxpayers frustrated and angry blame the
schools and the school board and the
teachers despite how hard everyone has
worked to keep the expenses down
this adversarial and often
confrontational situation harms the
community pitting schools and parents
with school-aged kids against other
taxpayers many of whom are retirees on a
fixed income
there seems to be no relief and no end
in sight this is unsustainable
depending on where you look online the
median household income in Hillsboro is
somewhere between fifty five thousand
and eighty thousand dollars a year
assuming the true figure is somewhere in
the middle it's obvious
number of homeowners in town could see
some real relief if this bill is signed
into law
from my constituents I hope the
committee will look favorably on hb504
while many tax cuts are being proposed
for businesses this year little is being
done about the largest tax New Hampshire
residents pay the property tax
hb504 addresses that
at least until the state can come up
with a more Equitable and Fair Way of
funding our Public Schools it offers
some hope for many including our
hard-working families and those on fixed
incomes thank you
thank you representative Porter any
questions for representative Porter
I don't see any
so the next would be a Jennifer boyiston
representing herself from the public and
the support
yes
this year
uh let me try that again I thought she
was there
um
foreign
yeah I I had her in and then oh here she
is let me do it again
yeah she's got her she just needs to
unmute yep
okay can you hear me now
yes Jennifer you signed up for in
support yeah in three minutes
yep sorry I am the technical difficulty
with my audio
yeah so I have
um just a quick comment that I'm pulling
up here
and I want to say thank you
uh for giving me the opportunity to um
talk with you today
and why can't I there we go sorry all
right I think I'm yeah and I'm I want to
testify in support of this bill
um and I'll start by saying that I live
in a small town in the Upper Valley
um which is called lime New Hampshire
um many people in our town uh recognize
the importance of public education and
they want to support our schools but
like most communities in New Hampshire
we have residents with a diversity of
incomes some of these incomes are very
high some of them are moderate and
others are low many of our residents are
retired and they live on fixed incomes
uh many of those retired members of our
community particularly live in a town
whose demographics have shifted
dramatically over the past two decades
and they may live in houses that are
currently assessed at values that they
would not have easily afforded when they
worked and earned income
as we build our budget as we build our
budgets for Town and school these
vulnerable residents are at the
Forefront of everyone's mind and we
struggle with a constantly increasing
costs of Education we make many
compromises particularly on Municipal
spending to manage costs and all of this
is done with the aim of protecting our
vulnerable residents
I I see this bill is imparting some
fairness to what I will admit I believe
is a fundamentally unjust system of
Taxation this isn't a cure-all but it
does attempt to address a serious
conflict and moreover as a previous
representative I think noted it does
address a common worry expressed by
so-called donor towns donor towns worry
about the ability of their retired and
low-income residents to be able to
afford their taxes
many towns across New Hampshire worry
about the same thing but we have to do
it without the help of state
subsidization of costs and I hope that
you'll keep that in mind as you consider
um the acceptance of this bill and thank
you for giving me the time to to talk
thank you for your testimony
um Mr loyalist and any questions from
the committee
any questions from the committee saying
none thank you very much
the next is from
representative McCutchen
elected officials
uh in opposition and he signed up for
three minutes
representative mkitchen
did I say right
can you hear me
yes thank you honorable chair and
members of the committee my name is
Diego McCarron and I come before you to
speak against House Bill 504 as
presented
as many of
have mentioned I don't wish to return to
the donor Town language of the past but
that's what this bill proposes to do I
was 715 New Hampshire Community sued the
state arguing that the education funding
system was unconstitutional 30 years
later I agree with the Supreme Court
that for the purposes of providing an
adequate education New Hampshire is one
Community I believe that every child in
New Hampshire should get the same
opportunities as I will strive to give
my two daughters I believe so strongly
because if it were not for my own
education and that of my parents I
wouldn't be sitting here in front of you
today
I speak today as more than a dad who
believes in education I'm a counselor
from the city of Portsmouth my hometown
I live across the street from the house
my dad grew up in and the one that my
grandfather built I didn't need to take
my dad's word for it that Portsmouth has
changed you have likely seen it for
yourself you might look at the rooms and
meals revenue and wonder if there's a
home cook among us but equally foolish
is to look at her assessed value and
believe a majority of folks could afford
to buy their homes at that price I
certainly couldn't I've only owned my
home for six years
my time on the council has shown me that
there are many struggling under their
property tax and we support the
provisions of tax relief but not how
this bill chooses to fund them a return
to a donor Town education funding model
through swept notwithstanding some of
the modest increase in deductions could
drive residents from ours and other
similarly situated communities
in any municipal election you speak to a
lot of people I love meeting new people
and hearing their stories but I hate
hearing a familiar refrain of neighbors
that don't know what to do because of
the property tax you know you're when a
budget might go up one to two percent
because of downshifting estate
responsibilities some tax bills will go
up 20 to 30 percent why valuations you
might point out Diego and increased
valuations mean lower tax rate the whole
reason you're here is that Portsmouth
has a lower tax rate than another
community that type of logic is halfway
there if you look at the rate and not
the valuation you miss what is driving
the pain because of comparable wholesale
home sale appraisal method your tax rate
can and often will fall in property-rich
areas only to see your taxes rise when
similar homes sell the similar appraisal
method required by the state in order to
fill our assessment duties means that
when a home in a neighborhood sells at
an increased value will cause other
houses to be assessed at higher values
which results in higher taxes creating a
vicious circle having a replace
education funding sent to the state
through the reinstatement of the donor
Town education funding model will only
accelerate this cycle many in these
communities will be forced to leave and
by their leaving will lose a piece of
our history
there are few that understand this last
point and still shrug their shoulders
are we supposed to cry for someone's
house increasing in value I hear that a
lot as if houses weren't places to raise
our families but investment vehicles
flip frequently in search of ever
increasing gains our communities are
places to rely on one another forming
bonds and friendships people we can
count on in a snowstorm when our forward
dies not just containers for investment
since everyone will sell in four to six
years once they maximize their profit
and are ready to bring their house to
the market like a farmer brings their
corn call me old-fashioned but I want
more than that in a house and a
community we're petulating a broken
system that will one day break for
everyone will first destroy communities
like Portsmouth I grew up here I stayed
here I want to be sharing stories with
the New Hampshire I know not telling
stories of the New Hampshire I remember
if you have any compassion for our
history and the people that make up each
donor town community if you believe like
I do the strength of a tree is not just
the new weeds and branches sprouting
looking for sunlight but also the roots
that dig deep into the soil then I ask
you to reject this Bill thank you for
your consideration
thank you for your testimony Mr kitchen
um questions
questions
and see any
time Mr chairman yes
Paul does Shane has has his hand up
since the second person
I would just say that he didn't sign up
ahead of time
um yeah I'm
right now I'm taking the ones that have
signed up to testify yeah through that
and we'll look at the others Mr chair
yes
um one other person that was on the list
that I gave you was uh Jeffrey Mick
Lynch
he's a school funding project you're
right and he's all obvious and I'm going
to take the lobbyist after I finish the
work that's just fine I just didn't want
him forgotten no there's another there's
two lobbyists have signed up and it's
actually not on anymore
oh Nick Lynch yeah I saw him earlier but
I just saw him
he's now at the top and he's got his
hands
we need to continue the time is running
out all right so um
the next as a Korean
c-a-s-c-a-d-d-e-n kassadin yeah
and she needs two minutes
hello am I all set with sound
yes yes you're all set great well
chairman major and committee members
thank you for this opportunity to
express the need for your support and
approval of house bill 504. I'm Karine
cascadden retired from 11 years as a
North Country School superintendent in a
45-year educator in both private and
public education
I've been serving as an active member on
the New Hampshire school funding
commission as well during this past year
my primary career was served for the
city of Berlin where there is an obvious
and clear lack of economic tax base to
supplement revenues from the local
property taxpayers I know budgets well
and have had to make decisions to
eliminate programs teachers
administrator positions and closed
school buildings in order to prevent the
city from Financial plight
just to give you uh noted different from
two communities that I am a property
owner in in 2009 for 2019
Berlin's overall property tax rate was
32.28 per thousand of value on an
equalized basis
that includes a local and State
education tax rate of 12.68
in the town of Arrow the overall rate
was 13.39 with a state
with a total state and local education
tax rate of just 5.86 needed to meet
very similar public education
requirements so legislators must work to
improve the equity of the New Hampshire
property tax system by remitting the
revenues from the Statewide education
property tax to the state we must
prevent the continuation of inequity of
funding our Public School Systems
house members have the power to ensure
the gap of student opportunities in our
Public Schools is decreased rather than
continue to be increased
all New Hampshire communities share the
need for a well-educated Workforce and
thus have the need for an equitable
education system
House Bill 504 stands to enhance
opportunities for property tax relief
for low and moderate income homeowners
in all communities
the sponsors of this film I'm sorry what
no the sponsors of this bill know
firsthand the need to change New
Hampshire school funding from the
dependents on local property taxpayers
to a Statewide tax system to equitably
fund a New Hampshire adequate education
this bill also requires revenue from the
Statewide education property tax to be
collected in a central manner via dra
for redistribution to the communities
who are in most need and who lack the
ability and resources to maintain their
public school programs
it is only a wish of North Country
School students to have the
opportunities and resources of other
wealthier towns I urge a committee to
vote in support of House Bill 504 as a
first step process toward providing an
equitable Statewide Public School
funding program that meets adequacy for
all communities not just property
wealthy ones and that increases
opportunities for all students not just
some I recommend you all review the
extensive work of the New Hampshire
school funding Commission in its final
report which is posted on the UNH car
seat School of Public Policy website if
you have not already
conclusions there were drawn from
research and facts please do your part
to assist New Hampshire property
taxpayers and I thank you today for your
undivided attention and time
thank you for your testimony
and any questions
any questions I don't see any
David
McLaughlin
mcgu c-k-i-n
on elective oh representative
in my town in opposition and it cost him
two minutes
mcgu c k i n no you you
I I didn't I've looked for him before
and didn't see him and I still don't see
him okay
now I will go back to
the obvious the Stephanie Gray
yes from the New Hampshire legal
assistance
and support next three minutes
it was definitely great yeah yeah I yes
there and she raised her hand and my
click didn't work so here she is
thank you can you hear me yes and you
go ahead
yes thank you my name is Stephanie Bray
and I'm here on behalf of New Hampshire
legal assistance
and this bill does three things in my
mind that are good and I don't think I
need a minute to talk about each of them
the first good thing that this bill does
perhaps nobody has noticed nobody's
mentioned it it amends RSA 76 section
11a to increase the visibility on
everyone's tax bill of the low the
availability of tax relief programs such
as low and moderate income but also
abatement and deferral and the other
programs that my clients would like to
benefit from they can't benefit from
those programs if they don't know they
exist and
um making the notice more prominent by
requiring it to be in bold 12 point type
is very sorely needed and so that's one
good thing
the second good thing that this bill
does is make the low and moderate income
property tax relief program uh more
generous and available to more people
and uh we are in favor of that as well
and the third good thing that this bill
does is the study committee
um which addresses
um how property taxes affect tenants
which I think is wonderful and
um not enough people have paid attention
to and also
um to be covered in the study committee
are the needs of people uh for deferral
of their property taxes so um I think
that is a very
um useful project so those are the good
things that uh we think this bill does
and I would be happy to take any
questions
great and Mrs Bray for you testimony
we do have
two people with questions representative
Army
thank you I'll be really quick on about
property tax deferrals I thought that
that was just to try to figure out a way
for the state to substitute for the
local deferrals do you find that local
deferrals are frequently not allowed
I find that a lot of towns don't even
know they're a thing
I have had to educate a few quite a few
towns that deferral is a thing
um I also have to explain
um what
um disabled means for purposes of
deferral and that deferral is available
to disabled persons in addition to
elderly persons
um so I hope that answers your question
thank you very much
[Music]
I I had my question answered thank you
okay any further questions
to make a lunch
is the lobbyist for the New Hampshire
school funding fairness project and
support and he signed up for three
minutes
good afternoon again the committee
members hear me all right
yes wonderful well chairman major
representative Almy and members of the
committee thank you so much for the
opportunity to testify before you this
afternoon for the record my name is Jeff
mclinch and I am indeed a lobbyist but
my sole client so to speak is the New
Hampshire school funding fairness
project where I am the Project Director
as houseville 504 would make New
Hampshire's tax system significantly
more fair
the New Hampshire school funding
fairness project strongly supports the
bill and urges the committee to
recommend it as ought to pass
as members of this committee are
uniquely aware you can't talk about New
Hampshire's tax system without talking
about the property tax it's far and away
the largest tax collected in New
Hampshire generating close to four
billion dollars to support state local
public services in 2019 well in excess
of any other form of Taxation levied in
the state
yet the property tax is also an unfair
tax as it places far greater
responsibility on low and moderate
income taxpayers than it does on more
affluent ones according to data from The
Institute on Taxation and economic
policy
the poorest fifth of New Hampshire
households paid 6.2 percent of their
incomes and property taxes in 2018. in
contrast the wealthiest one percent Each
of which enjoyed an income in excess of
over five hundred thousand dollars paid
an effective property tax rate of under
two percent
now despite its heavy Reliance on the
property tax and in turn that tax is
heavy tall and the least well off New
Hampshire does precious little to
mitigate the impact of the tax on those
struggling to make ends meet
um I think you all talked a little bit
today about the existing low and
moderate income property tax relief
program
sadly that program has all been
evaporated in recent years in 2003 it
had provided roughly seven and a half
million dollars in relief to over 27 000
Granite State households by 2018 those
figures have dwindled to fewer than 7
000 households receiving a total of just
1.1 million dollars in rebates even as
property taxes continue to climb
the bill before you this afternoon would
change that and change it dramatically
if enacted into law House Bill 504 would
significantly increase both the number
of homeowners eligible to receive relief
and the value of the rebates they would
receive I believe representative Ames
has already reviewed the change in the
various parameters so I don't want to
belabor that point but I do want to
emphasize that this bill would extend
or would change the programs that
applied not just to the Statewide
property tax
but to local school property taxes as
well and just to offer an example of
what that might mean for New Hampshire
family let's take a married couple
living in Charlestown
for the sake of this example let's
assume the couple has an income of about
forty five thousand dollars and lives in
a home worth a hundred fifty thousand
dollars
um in 2019 on an equalized basis the
local school property tax rate that they
paid was just over twenty dollars per
thousand the Statewide rate was 1.76 so
their property tax bills strictly for
schools purposes was about thirty three
hundred dollars
their overall bill is probably closer to
five thousand dollars or more than ten
percent of their total income
under current law they would not receive
any relief whatsoever because their
income was too high and even if their
income were sufficiently low the maximum
amount of relief they would receive
would be no more than about 180 dollars
if House Bill 504 became law they would
receive a rebate of one thousand dollars
a thousand dollars that they could use
at local businesses to put food on their
table eat in their home and gas in their
car
now
um this is one other aspect of the bill
has already been discussed so I don't
want to labor too much
but uh Hospital 504 does advance
taxpayer equity in one other critical
way as it would end the preferential
treatment
that some property wealthy
municipalities now enjoy under the
Statewide property tax
um many of you have heard before but in
Claremont 2 the Supreme Court ruled that
to the extent a property tax is used to
fund an adequate education the tax must
be administered in a way that's uniform
and rate throughout the state in its
current form the swept is far from
uniform cities and towns with
comparatively High property wealth are
permitted to retain any revenue from the
tax over and above what's needed to meet
the cost of an adequate education as a
result the swept in its present form
exacerbates the wide disparities in
school property tax rates that now exist
throughout New Hampshire
by restoring that swept as a true
Statewide tax House Bill 504 promotes
not only greater Equity but fiscal
responsibility too as the revenue
returning from this to the state from
swept would be used to offset the cost
of the additional rebates associated
with the property tax relief Provisions
those costs to be further limited by
capping individual rebates at no more
than a thousand dollars
uh as I conclude I just would like to
note that this committee has already
heard extensive testimony this session
about numerous changes in tax law to
Spur economic growth and to ease the
financial hardships arising from the
pandemic any effort to use New
Hampshire's tax system to achieve those
ends should start with House Bill 504 it
would put hundreds of dollars in the
pockets of Grant Staters still coping
with The Economic Consequences of the
pandemic and allow them to shop and
spend at local businesses striving to
remain open
for these reasons that once again urged
the committee to recommend House Bill
504 is off to pass and I look forward to
working with all of you if there should
be worse sex work sessions and I'd be
happy to answer any questions you might
have
thank you for your testimony Mr mcloanch
questions from
the committee representative thank you
Mr chair thank you Mr Mick Lynch for
your testimony going back to law and
moderate income homeowners property tax
relief which is under RSA 198 colon 57.
now that statute hasn't changed over the
years is that correct and so if that's
the case
then why is it that that the number of
people availing themselves to this is
occurring
so uh you're correct that
um in some respects it's not changed and
most notably the income thresholds that
you see uh in the bill have not changed
in those 15 years so um they've not kept
pace with inflation
um so naturally you would expect that
some people would become ineligible over
time the biggest consequence though is
changes in the Statewide property tax
itself as I believe was mentioned
earlier that tax used to be levied at
6.66 six dollars and sixty cents per
thousand which meant that it provided
greater relief relief and greater
incentive to folks to take part
um because of changes to bring that rate
down to under two dollars it no longer
delivers the same amount of relief that
it once did
thank you
representative spellsbury
thank you Mr chairman
uh Mr mcwench
um I understand the nature of the
problem you're describing and I would
Echo that you've chosen Charlestown
as a prime example that's the town I
represent
what I'm failing to see in this bill or
understand in the testimony
is how this would help to mitigate
the real estate property tax grade in
Charleston
you used a figure of a little over 24.
just to update
the budget that will be on our ballot
March 9th
will result in a local at a rate of
27.55
and when you combine that with the
squept
we're bumping right up against 30.
I don't see anything in this bill that
mitigates the overall burden on the
community which affects absolutely
everything in the community including
its desirability for anyone who to move
in open a business expand the business
mistakes
so where do we go
if the problems for property poor
communities is the effect of the rate on
the entire community
uh thank you very much for that question
representative
um I guess I would respond with a couple
of thoughts uh the first is that with
the property tax relief Provisions that
are in this bill
the effective rate to folks in
Charlestown will pay or at least the
effective rate for low and moderate
income folks in Charlestown were paying
would draw so that while the rate on
their bill might be the same as as you
just described they would be receiving a
check of up to a thousand dollars to
help offset those costs
the second thing I would mention is that
if depending on sort of the particulars
of how many people take up the property
tax release option
this bill would generate additional
funds to the to the order of 25 to 30
million dollars annually from restoring
yourself
funds that would then be available to be
redistributed in the way that they're
not now to cities and towns they're
really struggling to fund schools in an
adequate way and then the third point I
would offer is that um
the two um Chief ideas in this bill are
grounded in the work of the commission
that representative Ames and
representative Bluebell and Mr hardinger
all served upon and that the work of
that commission was extensive and
extended Beyond to address issues with
school funding to make it more Equitable
and I believe there's other legislation
now being considered
um in the senate in particular that
would act upon those recommendations in
listening to the testimony today
um you know I was reflecting upon the
nature of some questions about
um donor towns or towns that receive
property tax abatements that debate is
in large measure a function of the fact
that um School prop excuse me State
education Aid is woefully inadequate it
does not meet the full responsibility of
the state if State education Aid were
came closer to the actual cost that
Satan towns incurred in serving their
children we would not be having this
conversation at all about donor
attendance because that Aid would be
significantly more than what is
generated through the state property tax
today foreign
has his hands up
bringing them in
and thank you Mr chair and Paul as are
you testifying for or against and how
long
what happened to Paul
there we go
Paul sometimes are we there again are
you testifying for or against the bill
and how long do you plan I'll be very
short probably under two minutes and I'm
in opposition
um Logistics didn't prevent prevented me
from logging on earlier and noting that
so I apologize for that but I thank you
for the opportunity to join the group uh
this afternoon I represent or work for
the town of Newington and I'm providing
uh their opposition to the proposed uh
House Bill 504 and I will have written
commentary shortly to the uh staff to
circulate amongst you uh after uh the
committee uh session but to summarize uh
we applaud in town Newington that this
issue is being addressed the low and
moderate uh income house uh homeowner
property tax relief program uh has been
neglected for any number of years uh
however when the funding mechanism that
is envisioned here of providing the 25
million dollars in relief money comes
from only 46 communities uh in the state
who are going to end up turning over
approximately 28 million dollars over to
the state that's something that we don't
think is appropriate and is again
resumption of the donor and receiver
Town concept which the town of Newington
and others are uh opposed to now uh I
also object somewhat to the description
of these wealthy towns and versus poorer
towns I'll use an example if we're known
can itself yes it appears because of the
amount of the industry and Commercial
development of the town has
um then perhaps it has resources that
other towns don't but in terms of this
particular bill
I would like to point out of the 1.2
billion dollars worth of assessed value
nearly half of it is utility property
so only half of our tax base is going to
be able to contribute under this bill
towards our obligation uh envisioned and
that would be approximately uh eight
hundred and fifteen thousand dollars
that's 815 000 that is currently going
to support our children's education but
will have to be turned over to the state
and then re raise again locally in order
to make up that deficit
um so the impact to Residents uh here in
Newington is going to be significant
because of that proportional uh value of
of non-utility values uh is going to
have to be the tax base that's going to
support that the other thing that's
unfortunate the bill doesn't address is
is that it doesn't address a local uh
property tax relief in general it only
speaks to the state uh wide education
property tax uh so I think uh we all
agree that high property tax uh burdens
are uh are are significant to all
taxpayers regardless of their Source be
it a Statewide the local or education or
even the county so there's a there's a
disparity or our missing piece of tax
relief for these tax there's this
envisioned because it's only addressing
the Statewide property tax element
um lastly uh in a more personal
observation
um I would like to note that that
perhaps is a technical deficiency with
the bill under session one where it
speaks to uh uh turning over the excess
swept to the Department of Revenue
Administration it speaks to subtracting
municipal's actual costs of carrying out
the functions required in the
subdivision and later it defers to the
Department of Revenue Administration and
the commissioner of Education to
determine what those carrying costs are
I would like to and hope the committee
would entertain an amendment that would
uh spell out what those carrying costs
can be considered uh otherwise it's at
the full discretion of the two
Commissioners uh although I'm sure
they'll give due consideration in the
regulation development uh but I would
like to see a recognition that there are
carrying costs to any property tax
collection system which includes the
assessment of the property the billing
costs The Collection costs including
Administration lien and deeding costs uh
the cost of abatements which can be over
multiple years not just the current past
year so they have to be recognized over
uh two or more year period and of course
the lost interest income that if these
funds need to be turned over to the
state uh in an immediate faction after
the tax billing then there's no ability
or there's the loss function of a town
to have investment income off those
revenues so these are all carrying costs
that I think should be identified and
directed The Commissioners in their
process and determining uh what those
carrying costs are and then what they
should be in deducting out from the 28
million dollars that's going to be
collected so uh with that I'll leave my
testimony at that and let the written
testimony coming subsequently to speak
to itself
would you take questions
certainly uh representative Bromley
yeah I'm you
foreign
sorry about that I just wanted it's not
really a question I just want to say
hello to Paul oh he was on very first uh
Town Administrator in Stratham for when
he was there for nearly 30 years he
retired recently
so just want to say hello Paul
thank you Pat nice seeing you too
any questions from the committee of Mr
Duchene
you cannot see any and let me just check
it is there's nobody else signed up
on their list
there's 187
have signed up
in support of the bill
and 80 38 have signed up
in opposition to the bill
and I'm not going to read all the names
what the names of senior dollars
anybody else have any questions or
comments before I close the public
hearing on House Bill 504.
saying No Hands raised and I'm going to
close the public hearing on House Bill
504.
it takes two minutes and then we'll go
into the last bill of the day which is
supposed to start at two o'clock
um
get back to me back in two minutes
thank you
at least
okay
I'm going to open the public hearing on
House Bill 621--fm
enact allowing registered Deeds to
retain a portion of the Land Community
heritage
investment program surcharge
the prime sponsor is Rec representative
McConkey
and
he's busy here
I mean I just brought him in okay
yes thank you thank you
introducer Bill
thank you uh chairman major illustrious
members of ways and means for the record
my name is Mark McConkey I represent
Carroll County three hail from freedom
and once again serve as Vice chair on
public works
I'm before you today to ask your
committee to vote ought to pass on House
Bill 621
and I'm hoping that representative
janagan might be able to offer an
amendment to that at the appropriate
time uh it's the establishment of a
registry of deeds restoration account
under RSA 478 17K to retain an
additional 10 of the total additional
charges collected for the purpose of
funding the maintenance repair
restoration of land records and it
continues
I have served my County delegation for
more than seven terms and have been told
repeatedly by my registrar that the cost
to preserve our oldest land documents is
more is a presently a cost of more than
uh 11 million dollars
while we Whittle away at our need
registrar Lisa Scott
asked if the legislature might find a
way to contribute after much discussion
with my registrar Lisa Scott and she
with her fellow registrars We Believe
House Bill 624 is that vehicle
a letter uh was sent to the committee
and I hope you have which was uh
signed by eight of the ten registrars
offering their support for House Bill
and while Kathy and Stacy the Rockingham
register did not sign the letter of
endorsement she did also send a letter
to the committee dated February 5th and
that she says
not every County makes a commitment nor
can registrars commit funds for
preservation without the approval of the
commission is a delegation
unfortunately the importance of these
historical land records in many cases is
ignored should registration of the
historical land records continue to be
ignored
the result could be permanent
destruction due to deterioration of
these fragile documents in turn results
in the inability of research the title
to the land
how many Property Owners obtained clear
title a mortgage or sell their property
the land and Heritage investment program
can be applauded for its work to protect
Community landmarks but what good is a
landmark if historical title data cannot
be accessed at the registry of deeds
before and there'll be many behind me
with my red straw and others with more
to say but before I end my testimony I'd
like to address the physical node
attached on the original uh Ed on this
LSR
and um if amended I don't presume that
will change it would appear to me that
the land and Community Heritage
investment program l-chip funds nearly
33 projects on an average year those
projects are are if you were to average
amount or about a hundred and twenty one
thousand dollars a piece
the physical note said the anticipated
cost of this house bill would be 350 350
000 annually
which in which in my mind might result
in three less projects being granted
annually while I respect the work that's
done by l-chip
I believe that our bill here is worthy
of your consideration because those land
records are also historical documents
that need to be funded
I am happy to take any questions and I
will remind you that my registrar has
signed up to speak after me uh properly
with uh more detail on the bill with
that Mr chairman I'd happy to take any
questions if you have them at this late
hour
well thank you for your testimony
testimony representative McConkey
uh
Stenberg has a question
is that me Mr chairman is that too
representative Schamberg thank you thank
you Mr chairman and thank you for taking
my question representative in regards to
the importance of why this request to
retain a 10 portion of the l-chip
surcharge
uh is being made why wasn't a standalone
Bill introduced to add a new fee or
surcharge
that the registers could have added
other than proposing to take the l-chip
fund surcharge
thank you I um thank
um I thank you for the question
representative
the
l-chip presently is
is providing a four percent
surcharge on the documents that are
pertinent to this and in my
conversations with um
with legislative services and the
registrars
um uh we had not thought of the
direction that you're speaking of sir
and felt that this was fitting the place
inside this LSR excuse me inside this
RSA
I'm sorry
all set representative schemberg yes I
am thank you Mr chairman uh further
questions
I haven't seen any further questions so
we will go to
Elisa Scott
representative Scott from uh who was in
support of the bill he needs five
minutes to testify we representative
Scott
Mr chairman and representatives thank
you for the opportunity to testify in
favor of Bill
h-6 HB 621
I hope to only take two minutes of your
time
my name is Lisa I'm the Carroll County
Register of Deeds
an H Bill
HB 621
provides funding for the repair and
maintenance of the official land record
which is the foundation of private
property rights and our land and our
huge Community heritage
New Hampshire RSA 227 M colon 1. which
is the supporting legislation for the
community Heritage investment program
it states that the intent of the program
is to conserve and preserve the state's
most important natural cultural and
historical resources
through the acquisition of lands and
cultural and historical resources or
interests they're in
this bill proposes that the official
land record cared for at the registry of
deeds offices
is a significant cultural and historical
resource worthy of support of the
community and Heritage land investment
program
l-chip projects require proof of clear
title and a survey plan
both of which can only be achieved
through researching the records of the
registry of deeds
this fact demonstrates the close
relationship between the registry
records and the land in the human
Community Heritage investment program
l-chip grants rely on the evidence found
in the deeds and the plans recorded with
the registries
registry records are the foundation upon
which l-chip projects rest
and all infrastructures require
maintenance
the cost to repair and restore deeds and
plans is very high
and is currently born completely by the
counties
millions of dollars are needed to
properly care for the documents
passing this bill will provide
Registries funds to support restoration
of the documents without raising
additional fees or taxes
if passed the funds would only be used
to repair and restore the registry
records
and it would be supporting the
infrastructure which confirms our land
in our community heritage
and our property rights
I ask here to support HB 621
thank you for this opportunity
Victoria testimony Mrs Scott
um we do take any questions
of course representative
thank you Mr chairman and Scott on I was
on my County delegation executive
committee for 10 years something like
that and I remember
um that the Deeds office does more than
pay for itself all the time and that the
money provided from that uh in our case
in Grafton went
and goes to the upkeep of the Register
of Deeds office including a very
long-term project working on this and
I'm wondering whether uh somebody among
you is going to be able to tell us how
much money has been put
forth to this over the last five years
say and uh how far you've gotten back in
your Deeds records we'd gotten back
quite a ways when I left the executive
committee on and
um whether any of it gets taken off for
other functions of the county thank you
foreign
over the past five years four years here
at the registry
Carroll County has spent
approximately six hundred thousand
dollars on restoration of the records
and archival work
and yet we have gotten
through book one
35.
which is significant but it's not very
far into the books we're in book 3000
right now
we haven't started on the plans and the
plans are the majority of the cost
our delegation and the Commissioners
take this very seriously and have put
significant funds as you can tell from
the past five four years this year we
ask for more as well and yet the project
is so large
that
it's
a burden to the county
yes the county
does receive funding over and above what
the costs of the Deeds office are
and it is found the delegation has found
it necessary to use some of those funds
for other County functions
I ask every year
to
keep those funds within this office but
that's all I can do is to ask it's a big
problem for the counties particularly
the smaller counties that don't have
a lot of income
uh represented
Tucker
no I
I was going to ask the very same
question so I put my hand in
representative Bromley
I want to make sure I thank you very
much Mr chair
um thank you for your testimony
um is it Miss Scott
um let's just make sure we all
understand so four percent there's
currently a four percent surcharge
on top of the real estate transfer tax
is that correct
we're talking about the El chip
surcharge which is assessed on four
different documents 25 dollar per
document document fee
and as an administrative
costs the counties keep four percent and
the 96 percent goes to the state which
then in turn gives it to the l-chip
trust fund right I already know we are
asking for an additional 10 percent
of that fee
for the specific purpose of restoration
and repair of the records just follow up
on make sure I understand so of the of
the four percent on these document fees
that's going to to LT if you you would
like to see up to 10 percent
uh taken from lchip and used for this
purpose is that correct
would you allow me to reword that
yeah that's why I asked the question yes
okay incorrectly
four documents recorded with 25 worth of
fees each hundred dollars when at the
end of the month we send our money to
the state of New Hampshire four percent
is withheld to the county and given to
the treasurer to administer
collecting the funds we're asking for an
additional 10
an additional 10 percent to be retained
by the county and put in a separate
designated fund specifically for the use
of repair and restoration of the records
therefore we'd be sending 86 percent of
the funds received for l-chip
to the state of New Hampshire which
would then pass it on to the l-chip
trust
all right I'm a little confused I'm
usually not this thick so
um so does will L chip get less money
for their normal purposes uh from this I
guess it's another way of trying to
understand this
l-chip will receive less funds for their
[Music]
yes
the answer is uh you complicated yes
because I believe that the l-chip
Grant the law
includes land and cultural heritage
which Deeds are a part of that plans are
a part of that we hold here the
documents that prove that l-chip grants
are legitimate
so in my mind the Deeds fall under the
l-chip
law
and so would l-chip receive the ex that
10 percent
they wouldn't get the money in hand but
the money would be spent to justify
their projects representative Romney if
you look at the fiscal note L chip gets
about
three and a half million dollars a year
from this special assessment for
documents and what they're asking for is
ten percent of that which is about 350
000 a year the whole toys this
restoration
350 000 does not go to l-chip for other
purposes correct right that's what I
want to clarify thank you yeah I read
this yeah thank you
represented
Hamburg
I I guess I'm I'm
I guess the question I have Miss Scott
thank you Mr chairman is that
you're wanting another 10 on top of the
present four percent
that
is presently taken out of the surcharge
and
is this number 350 000 including is this
the total will be 14 now is that 350 000
or is there or is it higher is it like
more 400 and some thousand that will be
taken
overall
it would be a total of 14 taken whatever
amount is taken and this past year
Carroll County uh well I I can't address
how much money l-chip has received from
the L chip uh surcharge except for what
is on the uh initial bill which says it
was 3.5 million
14 of that would be retained at the
county level each County would get 14
okay thank you thank you Mr Scott
any other questions
when
representative McCarthy
testify and support and representative
McConkey said he would need four minutes
isn't he the prime sponsor that he spoke
did already oh I'm sorry
Sheila Vargas next is that right it
would be a long day
yes Sheila Vargas okay
in the lobbyists from the nature of
conservative
and opposes the bill
and needs three minutes
thank you chairman major I hope my audio
is all right and I am hoping I can also
spare all of you and not use the
entirety of the three minutes as I have
submitted written testimony as well
I would also just like to State for the
record my name is Sheila Vargas I'm the
government and community relations
manager for the nature conservancy in
New Hampshire and I am here testifying
in opposition to House Bill 621 FN and I
will be testifying not only for The
Nature Conservancy but also for New
Hampshire Audubon for the Appalachian
Mountain club and New Hampshire Lakes we
have provided joint testimony for you
today
so we are opposed to this bill for a
number of reasons
currently I'll check fees are collected
from recording fees assessed for certain
documents as you heard by the 10 New
Hampshire County register of deeds and
transferred to the state treasury into
the dedicated fund which is administered
by the l-chip program so I'm just going
to skip over some of uh the housekeeping
portions of our opposition as you've
heard
um the reasons why and how the funds go
into the dedicated fund that was created
by RSA 227m I would like to note uh the
previous individuals who testified in
support of the bill
clearly stated that the dedicated fund
RSA 227m does state that the funds are
to be used to conserve and preserve the
state's most important natural cultural
and historical resources what they
failed to continue with that statement
and continue saying was the remainder of
that RSA a which clearly states through
the acquisition of lands and cultural
and history through the acquisition of
lands and cultural and historical
resources or interests therein of local
Regional and Statewide significance in
partnership with the state's
municipalities and the private sector
for the primary purposes of protecting
and ensuring the Perpetual contributions
of these resources to the state's
economy environment and overall quality
of life nothing within this RSA if read
in its entirety it states that these
funds can should be used for the
purposes outlined in house bills
sorry I'm just I'm getting a little
feedback from someone's mic I think uh
finally the bill would deprive a popular
and over subscribed program of needed
Revenue to fulfill its statutory
obligation aside from the obligations of
maintaining the Integrity of l-chip's
dedicated fund there is also a clear
need to prevent any funds from being
diverted from this highly popular
program from which applicants for
funding consistently exceed the funds
available and I believe digit who is
with l-chip is here to testify and can
speak to that more closely alchem is
often held up in our state as a model
for how State dollars can achieve
tremendous leverage and bring tangible
benefits to the state's people this is
something we should be looking to build
upon and not weaken a big part of the
success of this model is its Statewide
Focus along with dedicated and trained
staff capacity to make sure resources
are being used in the most effective way
possible l-chip has trained professional
staff and qualified boards at board
members that work with a variety of
stakeholders to make judgments and
decisions to ensure LG expenditures are
in the public interest I would also like
to note that this bill is frankly
unnecessary as counties can raise the
capital needed to meet their needs
without rating a state program the
counties do set their own budgets as you
are well aware raise their own revenue
and have access to Municipal and private
sector bonds which are at historically
low interest rates currently all of
these options are available to meet the
priorities of County government these
options would also provide the counties
a quicker and more holistic solution to
achieving their goals the proposed
l-chip fund raid brings in only a small
percentage of the funding necessary to
complete the proposed work meaning many
years will be required to complete the
task there other funding options
available to the counties as you clearly
just heard from the previous speaker
that would more quickly meet the needs
and are better aligned with the proposed
project
with that and actually before I before I
conclude I would like to note that
according to l-chip every dollar
invested by this program into our
state's natural and historic resources
leverages an additional five dollars in
investment which makes l-chip a very
efficient use of public dollars and so
with that our organizations New
Hampshire Lakes The Nature Conservancy
New Hampshire Audubon and the
Appalachian Mountain Club jointly ask
that this committee vote and expedient
to legislate on this bill and continue
our state's long-standing tradition of
not only valuing our natural resources
but also upholding the Integrity of a
dedicated fund with a long history of
bipartisanship
thank you for your testimony Mrs vagus
uh questions from the committee
questions from the committee
saying none and we will go on to a will
Stewart proposal lobbyist with uh
stay work play New Hampshire in
opposition to the bill and it says two
minutes
and let's see how close he goes to two
thank you Mr chairman I will try to keep
it under two minutes for sure
um again for the record stay work play
uh I'm will Stewart the executive
director and stay work play is a
Statewide non-profit whose mission is to
attract and retain young people
um you might recall I was before the
committee this morning talking about the
study committee with regard to you know
child care and uh here again to um to
speak to this bill and to State our
opposition I think Ms Vargas you know
gave a great explanation of why it's a
bad idea and uh you might recall in my
earlier testimony I mentioned that about
three years ago that stay work play
commissioned a survey to collect data on
why young people you know stay in and
might leave New Hampshire and uh the
number one reason we found and that uh
in that survey that young people stay
here is access to our state's
unparalleled natural resources and we
heard this again last fall and winter as
we talked to young people in nine
locations across the state as part of
our policy and pint series
so you know to our mind we want to do
all that we can to to maintain and to
the extent we can enhance you know our
state's uh natural resources our our
Golden Goose if you will and uh so you
know we oppose on principle any uh
any proposition to reduce or or kill
this Golden Goose that is our state's
natural resources and for that reason
you know we ask you to uh to vote in
expedient to legislate on this Bill
thank you thank you Mr Stewart uh any
questions
we go to
representative Gigan
suppose go to the bill
thank you Mr chairman I I signed up I
may have signed up apparently because I
signed up because the prime sponsor
representative McConkey asked me to
introduce an amendment to the bill but
is that amendment to be introduced
during a work session or would you want
to introduce now
you could introduce it now uh but you
can also introduce in the work session
okay well I guess in the interest of
time we'll we'll introduce it in the
work session it's a minor change that
clarifies
um and creates a register of deeds
restoration account under RSA 478 17K so
it's pretty straightforward so I think
we'll introduce I can introduce it
during our work session I thank you
representative
thank you the um
[Music]
on the list that I have unless there's
somebody else in the attendee I just let
digit Taylor in she was the last one
to testify
yes she signed up for zero minutes
sorry about that it was my first time
signing up and I missed the block on the
Forum
and how long do you plan on testifying
under five minutes but I probably know
more about l-chip than anybody else on
this call so I think what I have to say
may be interesting to you
all right
do the five minutes but I'm gonna cut
you off at five I think that's fair you
all have had an incredibly long day I
listened in on the previous Bill and
that was only one of many that you had
sat through representative major and the
rest of the committee thank you very
much for hearing me and for the hard
work that you put in every day to keep
the state running as smoothly as
possible I am digit Taylor I've been the
executive director of L chips since 2010
it is a great honor to serve the state
in this capacity we think and we've been
told repeatedly that we are one of the
best functions that the state provides
to the citizens
LG was created in 2000 by the
legislature with overwhelming support
and its purpose is described in the
first paragraph of the statute which Ms
Vargas read to you recently
um the we are intended to conserve and
preserve important natural cultural
historic resources through acquiring
land or interest in lands and resources
with matching grants and public private
private Partnerships so the difference
between what we do and what this
proposal has is we acquire land and
interest in lands and we do it through
matching grants neither of which seems
to be quite the case with this proposed
legislation we have a long history of
success I hope you have in front of you
the beautifully colored handouts that I
provided for you showing some examples
of l-chip projects and listing listing
the numbers of projects we've done and
so forth but given the length of your
day I will not try to read through all
of those
oops just lost my notes
um
you probably want to know
where our money comes from and all of
the money that we give out in Grants
comes from these fees that are are
collected at the Registries of Deans
this this was created in 2009 as a
dedicated fund to support our grant
making
um and these fees currently bring us in
about three and a half to four million
dollars a year the registry is as Ms
Scott said get to keep five percent of
that to cover their time and trouble in
collecting the fees
um and the estimates that are in the
fiscal note come largely from my
estimates and
um so the amount of money that l-chip
would get if this were to be enacted
would be less and we would be less able
to
respond to the requests that we get for
funding we already do not have enough
money to meet the the requests that we
get from applicants last year we
received 65 applications looking for
nearly nine million dollars in 2019
there were 67 757 applications looking
for seven and a half million dollars and
we just the the three and a half to four
million dollars just isn't enough so
we're turning down really good projects
simply because we don't have enough
money
we agree that the archival restoration
of the official land records is
important to everyone who deals with
real estate in transactions in the state
not just to L ship however protecting
them and preserving them is outside the
realm of what the legislature wisely
created for l-chip to do
it is of course up to the legislature to
decide what to do with this bill but to
me it doesn't make sense to give l-chip
less money when we are all we're already
flooded with requests for the money that
we do have and the less money would be
going to something that our program was
not designed to protect
thank you and I'm happy to answer
questions if that is helpful and if you
have the tolerance for it
that is great you only use three three
minutes sofa
our questions uh hold on one second okay
give me the right to panelists
represent Elmer
thank you Mr chairman
um we I'm on my Conservation Commission
and I think we did manage to use
partially l-chip once we do a lot more
land acquisition than that because we've
got a strong uh fund from our uh
property current use property coming out
into development but on my question was
I've been under the impression that the
local community has to raise about half
the money ahead of time before they can
apply for one of these so that they can
go ahead with the project once they've
got your part of it on and it's on
considerable risk for them when you can
only provide half of of the applicants
with a grant
yes absolutely you're absolutely right
that we do require matching funds we
don't require that it be in hand at the
time of the application being submitted
but a project that has that money in
hand scores better than one that does
not a more recent two more recent
projects in Lebanon the Rogers house
which is elderly housing and the um the
music school the upper Upper Valley
Music School across the across the Green
from from the Rogers house so we have
done some nice historic preservation
projects in Lebanon as well
yes I'd just like to add that Rogers
house was the Rogers Hotel and I think
dates back about 150 years and The
Highwaymen and other things like that
you had your own pirates in Lebanese
elderly housing
uh further questions of
Mrs Taylor
saying none thank you for your testimony
thank you for listening
do we have anybody else
there is one more hand raised
not um signed up uh a actually there's
two now a Matt Leahy and a Jeffrey
Gilbert
okay um
oh
let's find out Matt Leahy okay I'm
letting him in
hi good afternoon Mr chairman I hope you
all can hear me
um Mr Leahy are you in support or
opposition uh I am opposed to the bill
and for the record
um my name is Matt Leahy I work for the
forest society and how long do you uh no
more than two minutes I'll be very brief
um and just you know for the record uh
the four Society has received l-chip
grants um in the past just so I just
want the community to know that but as I
said we are opposed to the bill and
although we you know we do understand
the importance you know to the counties
maybe lean into your microphone
is this better yes okay yeah so we do
understand the importance to the
counties too
um you know undertake this repair and
archival work our concern is though that
this work is going to be coming
um or or at places at least part of the
burden on l-chip to undertake
um and I would just point out one thing
that
um you know State Statute at 478 colon 1
actually puts the responsibility for
this type of work on the counties not on
Belcher and as digit mentioned
um you know this you know taking this
additional money from l-chip's budget
will something
um you know put more pressure on l-ship
to carry out its Mission and to try to
meet the demand for its programs and so
again we are opposed to the bill
thank you well thank you for your
testimony Mr lady
questions
[Music]
switch over here
I don't see any questions so the next
one is Mr chairman I believe that Jeff
Gilbert is the Jeff Gilbert that was
your Vice chair a long time ago oh I'm
ready to bring them in right now
but I mean
Jeff Gilbert I don't know he said I I
hope you folks can hear me first of all
it's a privilege to come before this
committee again and representative Olney
is correct
um I served uh under the uh leadership
of uh chairman Majors uh quite some
years ago uh as Vice chair and greatly
enjoyed my opportunity to work with you
folks and and in particular of course uh
have been a long time champion of el
chip uh and also as representative Omni
specifically knows have taken a strong
interest in dedicated funds and
dedicated funds being used properly for
the purposes for which they were
dedicated in the initial instance and uh
uh also with full disclosure of what the
funds do I'm appearing here the the this
afternoon on behalf of the New Hampshire
preservation Alliance of which I am a
trustee uh and we urge the rejection of
House Bill 621 which as you you all have
heard a great deal of testimony about is
diverting funds from this program uh for
other purposes which are not uh those
that are Central to the program itself
uh there's been certainly much testimony
so I'll try not to take very long but to
just emphasize a couple of points uh the
dedicated fund was originally conceived
as one which had Nexus uh to the
purposes of l-chip the source of funding
in fact uh makes a great deal of sense
when you consider that l-chips programs
indeed contribute significantly to the
quality of life in New Hampshire and
enhance as a result of that not only the
enjoyment of our citizens of so many of
our resources both be they land or be
they cultural or be the historic but it
also raises property values in the
process
and one of the key things that are two
key points I'd like to re-emphasize the
program has been under has been
oversubscribed and underfunded for many
many years this is a program which
historically as I believe Digi Taylor
testified uh has nearly two or two and a
half times the demand with quality
projects uh that simply uh can't be
funded so any diversion of funds from
this uh purpose would be a significant
dilution of its great uh goals and
objectives which I think have truly been
remarkable in what they've done for the
state over the 20 years of the program
one element that is particularly
significant is that often l-chip funds
serve as the critical Equity component
for a project because it is a grant and
as a grant uh often is essential to add
to other sources of funding as I think
digit testified almost all the projects
require significant additional funding
and l-chip achieves that ability to
leverage that that funding whether it's
from Bank sources or whether it's from
Community uh funds that are raised
otherwise so it it produces a five or
six to one benefit to the communities
that that the projects are located in uh
and makes the community stronger creates
additional uh community support and
overall I think improves our quality of
life I certainly hope that you do uh
take the step in itl the bill uh l-chip
if anything needs considerably more
funding not less
and I'd be happy to take any questions
thank you for your testimony uh Jeff
representative Brantley has a question
Mr chair um Mr Gilbert thank you for
your testimony
so being being a state rep for a while
there you you probably had a chance to
observe County Government
and I think it was mentioned earlier
that most Registries of Deeds generate
more Revenue
than they their expense therefore the
counties use the excess for other things
within the county
is that is that your observation as well
that that is generally my understanding
and and uh not speaking to the merits or
demerits of preserving the records which
I think is a lofty goal it's just this
shouldn't be the source of funding for
that goal the county uh has other
resources available to it uh which some
of which could be short-term uh such as
uh the typical uh annual funds but also
long term in terms of bonding uh the
comments were made today bonding is at a
extraordinary low cost for uh for for
the counties which could be utilized uh
very readily for this purpose uh and not
uh be deluding uh the the other enormous
benefits that l-chip brings thank you
any other questions for Mr The Honorable
Jeffrey Gilbert
I don't see any thank you thank you all
any further
people wish to testify for or against
house bill 621.
if not I'm going to close the hearing on
House Bill 621 and we will be addressing
it
at a work session on the 2nd of March
a long day
wait any any comments from the committee
if not then we'll call it quests
thank you
[Music]
okay